herzlich willkommen zufolge 201 des faz
einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast der faz für recht justiz und
politik heute am 9 märz
2022 mein name ist grüner budras ich bin
berlin korrespondent in der faz und mit
dabei ist wieder pure ins freie
journalisten und juristen aus köln
wollen ja uns beschäftigt natürlich
wieder der krieg in der ukraine wie
sollte es auch anders sein und dazu
erreichen uns auch immer wieder fragen
von hörerinnen und hörern herzlichen
dank dafür
wir müssen so ein bisschen um
verständnis bitten wenn wir nicht alle
sofort beantworten können denn auch
heute haben wir wieder eine wirklich
sehr volle sendung wird übrigens auch
ein kleiner interview-marathon das kann
ich schon mal ankündigen
es gab viel zu sagen und wir beginnen
mit einem interview mit professor claus
kreß mit dem hast du gesprochen corinna
worüber genau das gefühl sehr viele
themen gerade was die völkerrechtler so
angeht genau klar es ist eben inhaber
des lehrstuhls für deutsches und
internationales strafrecht an der
universität zu köln und er leitet dort
auch das institut für friedenssicherung
recht ja und da an man schon wohin die
reise geht er wurde in mich außerdem vom
ankläger des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs zum special advisor an
land und das ist für uns natürlich
besonders spannend denn das völkerrecht
auch das völkerstrafrecht er lebt ja
gerade ein ziemlich ungewöhnlichen
höhenflug das hätte wahrscheinlich kaum
jemand gedacht wir sprechen immer das
verfahren das die ukraine vor dem
internationalen gerichtshof der
vereinten nationen angestrengt hat und
auch über die ermittlung des
chefanklägers am internationalen
strafgerichtshof
die womöglich irgendwann mal dazu führen
dass der russische präsident putin vor
dem kriegsverbrechertribunal landet auch
wenn man es irgendwie im moment noch ein
kaum zu hoffen wagt was man
ehrlicherweise auch mal sagen ja und wir
sprechen dann auch noch über das
russische zensurgesetz das seit
vergangener woche auch für viel
aufregung und empörung sorgt pia und du
hast uns auch was mitgebracht
habe mit dr matthias lehnert gesprochen
im vorfeld dieser folge und zwar über
die frage was eigentlich die
ukrainerinnen und die ukraine die jetzt
nach deutschland kommen hier dürfen
welchen status haben die eigentlich
genau wo wohnen die wovon leben die
dürfen die arbeiten gehen also das ist
ein relativ lebensnahes stückchen
information dass ich uns damit gebracht
habe was vielleicht auch mal so ein
bisschen hoffnung bietet in den
aktuellen zeiten die ja irgendwie wenig
anlass zur hoffnung geben aber wie sich
da die eu aufstellt und wie sich da auch
deutschland aufstellt und mit offenen
armen die leute aufnimmt das ist ja
vielleicht auch ganz schön zu hören und
übrigens alles noch gar nicht so sicher
und durchdekliniert wie man das immer so
liest mit meinem kollegen markus jung
sprechen noch über die russen connection
die viele kanzleien in london und in
deutschland liegen beziehungsweise
gepflegt haben und wir gehen der frage
nach inwieweit die nun von den
weitreichenden wirtschaftssanktionen
betroffen sind obwohl ja anwälte selber
nicht ins ziel gerückt sind aber
natürlich hängen sie da auch mit drin
und das wirkt sich auf ihre arbeit aus
und dann haben wir noch zwei mal das
verwaltungsgericht köln du hast noch
relativ spontan mit helene borowski
gesprochen corinna denn schon gestern
abend kamen auch die entscheidung dass
die afg als verdachtsfall eingestuft
werden darf und aus der vergangenen
woche haben wir ebenfalls das
verwaltungsgericht in köln dass die
meldepflicht nach dem netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz für unions
rechtswidrig erklärt und erstmal im
eilverfahren gekippt das ist ein
harmloses thema auf dass ich mich
wirklich freue in diesen zeiten ja nur
um so etwas profanes und wir haben auch
noch profane nachträge zum thema
genesenen status genau nachträge und
eine höhere post die gar nicht so profan
ist natürlich das gerechte urteil ist es
wenigstens launig 4 naja es ist launig
ist vielleicht jetzt auch das falsche
wort denn es gibt geht eigentlich schon
wieder und asylrecht es geht aber auch
ein strafrecht es geht um das bayerische
oberste landesgericht und die haben
einen freispruch bestätigt für einen
mönch der einem geflüchteten kirchenasyl
gewährt hatte und zwar mit einer
sensationellen argumentation also das
ist wirklich was drauf rollen
wir beginnen den podcast also mit dem
krieg in der ukraine und dem völkerrecht
und dafür dass das völkerrecht immer als
zahnloser tiger gilt ja dafür ist ganz
schön viel bewegung in dem thema und
dazu habe ich mich jetzt verabredet mit
dem kölner professor claus kreß ich
hatte es eben schon gesagt er ist
inhaber des lehrstuhls für deutsches und
internationales strafrecht einer
universität zu köln und er leitet das
dortige institut für friedenssicherung
recht und beginnen möchte ich jetzt
einmal mit dem was aktuell auf dem tisch
liegt die ukraine hat russland vor dem
internationalen gerichtshof verklagt
herr gress was steckt dahinter
ja zu ihrer eingangs bemerkung
vielleicht noch das ist in der tat
richtig
und sehr beeindruckend auf wie vielen
ebenen die ukraine man muss sich ja
vorstellen in welcher situation sich
dieser staat mit seinem personal im
moment befindet die völkerrechtlichen
instrumentarien nutzt und da ist in der
tat der internationale gerichtshof das
haut rechtsprechungs organ der vereinten
nationen zuständig für
zwischenstaatliche
streitigkeiten ein beispiel und ein sehr
aktuelles der das hauptanliegen der
ukraine vor dem internationalen
gerichtshof ist es
diesen zu einer feststellung zu bewegen
dass die völkermord vorwürfe die putin
im rahmen seines seiner in
anführungszeichen rechtfertigung
vorgetragen hat dass diese völkermord
vorwürfe haltlos sind in den
uns vertrauten
nationalen kategorien ist das so etwas
wie eine negative feststellungsklage auf
die die ukraine zielt
also für alle juristen die können
natürlich damit was anfangen aber
tatsächlich auch für nichtjuristen und
nicht aus sind kann man vielleicht an
dieser stelle mal sagen dass das klingt
recht nüchtern und unaufgeregt so
negatives feststellung interesse also
das gibt es eben auch in der juristerei
an vielen stellen dass man einfach mal
was festgestellt haben möchte natürlich
dass ich dann im zuge dessen auch das
eine oder andere damit verbindet
vielleicht schadensersatzansprüche oder
so dass es wäre so eine typische
konstellation aber
interessant ist er tatsächlich das in
dieser aufregung in dieser prekären
situation tatsächlich die ukraine den
wunsch hat das einmal klären zu lassen
lässt sich eigentlich russland darauf
ein russland lässt sich bislang nicht
darauf ein russland nimmt bisher am
verfahren nicht teil und noch einmal zu
dem punkt den sie gerade angesprochen
haben das klinge nüchtern ist aber doch
vermutlich sehr brisant ja es ist
hochbrisant was da so nüchtern in der
prozessrechtlichen
sprache im prozessrechtlichen vokabular
negative feststellungsklage daherkommt
denn das ist ja eben dieser völkermord
vorwurf ein zentraler baustein in diesem
ich sage es immer wieder in
anführungszeichen
rechtfertigung paradigma putins und
daran sind sie haben nach den
konsequenzen gefragt über die negative
feststellung hinaus damit verbindet nun
die ukraine
das begehren auch vorgetragen vor dem
internationalen gerichtshof einer ganz
handfesten konsequenz und zwar des
antrags dass russland seinen angriff auf
die ukraine unmittelbar einstellen möge
jetzt müssen wir präzise sein diesen
antrag hat die ukraine im rahmen des
jähnigen verfahrens abschnitts gestellt
der im moment läuft und das ist das
jetzt in kalorien des deutschen rechts
den vertrauten kategorien so etwas wie
vorläufiger rechtsschutz die ukraine hat
vor dem internationalen gerichtshof
den antrag gestellt eine angst
einstweilige anordnung gegen russland zu
erlassen und die zentrale einstweilige
anordnung auf die eu die ukraine zählt
ist stopp des laufenden angriffs und das
ist nun interessant wir hatten eingangs
gesagt die ukraine bedient hier bedient
sich hier ganz vieler
völkerrechtlicher instrumente
gleichzeitig das ist jetzt sehr
interessant im vergleich zu dem was der
europäische menschenrechtsgerichtshof
bislang getan hat denn den hat die
ukraine auch angerufen auch um
einstweilige anordnungen gebeten der
europäische menschenrechtsgerichtshof
hat sehr schnell gehandelt durch seinen
präsidenten das verfahren dort ist
vergleichsweise
informell und hat das ist sehr sehr
bemerkenswert vor dem hintergrund seiner
früheren rechtsprechung
hat eine einstweilige anordnung erlassen
allerdings nicht dahingehend aus
rechtlichen gründen nicht dahingehend
dass der angriff insgesamt
gestoppt werden solle sondern
begrenzt darauf dass zivilisten
im zuge der kampfhandlungen geschützt
werden dass angriffe auf zivilisten
unterbleiben
der grund der hintergrund für diese
eingeschränkte einstweilige anordnung
ist dass der europäische
menschenrechtsgerichtshof das grundrecht
auf leben im lichte des völkerrechts der
bewaffneten konflikte aus legt daher
also dieser engere tenor und das an
wegen der ukraine vor den
internationalen gerichtshof geht jetzt
wiederum im einstweiligen
rechtsschutzverfahren darüber hinaus
also das interessante ist also präsident
lenski versucht nicht nur die leute die
männer an die waffen zu holen sich zu
verteidigen sondern er beschreitet auch
wirklich jeden erdenklichen
völkerrechtlichen weg um russland zu
stoppen wie ungewöhnlich ist denn so was
also in dieser
konzentration in der wir das im moment
erleben ist das schon sehr bemerkenswert
aber froh dass die situation ist ja auch
denkbar dramatisch das eigentlich
bemerkenswerte
daran finde ich mit welcher virtuosität
ein land in einer situation
existenzieller bedrohung auch die kraft
man möchte fast sagen die ruhe findet zu
solchen schritten in solcher zahl und
was aber könnte er sich davon
versprechen denn auch ein präsident
selensky wird ja nicht so naiv sein zu
sagen dass sich ein putin der russische
präsident davon auch von einem
gerichtsurteil in die schranken weisen
lässt was möchte er damit erreichen
mein sohn ali wird er sicher nicht sein
es geht sicherlich jetzt ganz aktuell
auch darum den narrativen die putin mit
allen erdenklichen mitteln der
propaganda in szene gesetzt hat jetzt
die stimme des rechts entgegen zu setzen
und natürlich
klingt die stimme des rechts
gesprochen von internationalen
gerichtshöfen der internationale
gerichtshof über gehen wir jetzt
gesprochen haben das ist der
altehrwürdige
schüler der völker rechtsordnung
natürlich klingt diese stimme
ganz oder klänge wenn sie denn ertönte
ganz besonders eindrucksvoll und darum
geht es in dieser auseinandersetzung der
ukraine ganz sicher auch auf allen
erdenklichen wegen
jetzt so schnell wie möglich deutlich zu
machen dass man selbst fest auf dem
boden des rechts des völkerrechts steht
dass die völker rechtsordnung hier
insgesamt angegriffen wird dass es sie
zu verteidigen gilt vor einem aggressor
wie ist denn das stand des verfahrens
also wir hatten mündliche verhandlungen
russland ist nicht erschienen die
ukraine hat anträge gestellt wie geht es
jetzt weiter
ich vermute schwer dass die richter des
internationalen gerichtshofs jetzt
beraten und dann wäre der nächste
schritt eine entscheidung über diese
anträge noch einmal ganz wichtig im
vorläufigen rechtsschutz und dann geht
das verfahren im übrigen seinen gang
dann werden zunächst einmal auch fragen
der
zuständigkeit des gerichtshofs im
vordergrund stehen wie genau prozess war
das wird dann weiter davon abhängen ob
sich russland beteiligt oder nicht aber
die zuständigkeitsfrage sie ist immer
beim internationalen gerichtshof eine
bedeutsame woran liegt das das liegt
daran dass man ein internationales
gericht nicht einfach so anrufen kann
wie wir das im nationalen recht gewohnt
sind für die internationale
gerichtsbarkeit
gilt dass konsens prinzip also
ganz konkret der
internationale gerichtshof kann nur dann
entscheiden wenn er sich im hinblick auf
den streitgegenstand auf eine wie auch
immer geartete zustimmung beider
parteien berufen kann dies zu dürfen und
um diese frage kreisen dann häufig schon
sehr sehr erhebliche rechtsfragen hier
in diesem fall ist die zuständigkeit
basis die die ukraine geltend gemacht
hat ein bestimmter sehr sehr wichtiger
völkerrechtlicher vertrag
die sogenannte völkermord konvention
denn in dieser konvention gibt es eine
sogenannte gerichtsstandsvereinbarung
dieser klausel erfüllt sind das ist
deshalb wichtig weil beide staaten die
ukraine und russland
parteien dieses vertrages
also das ist ein verfahren das gerade
läuft das noch lange dauern wird
voraussichtlich das auch keine
unmittelbaren konsequenzen hat außer
festzustellen dass womöglich dieser
krieg jeglicher rechtfertigung
entbehrt also es gibt überhaupt keine
dass da hofft sich eben präsident sein
es geht dass am ende dieses verfahren
steht die feststellung dass putin dass
russland ohne grund quasi gewalt
angewendet hat und die souveränität des
staates verletzt hat doch etwas präziser
bitte frau gerne dass hier die da geht
es wirklich um wichtige chancen es geht
nicht um die allgemeine feststellung der
unrechtmäßigkeit des russischen gewalt
einsatzes sondern es geht präziser um
die feststellung dass russlands
völkermord vorwurf
gerichtet an die ukraine nicht zutrifft
und das hat jetzt wieder diese engere
stoßrichtung hat wieder zu tun mit der
eben angesprochenen zuständigkeitsfrage
nur insoweit gibt es möglicherweise eine
zuständigkeit das hat natürlich dann
oder hätte eine solche feststellung
implikationen aber der gerichtshof
selbst könnte nur zu dieser
fragestellung
dann kommen wir doch jetzt mal zu dem
zweiten strang also ein mögliches
strafverfahren von dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof ich betone dass
deswegen so deutlich um klar zu machen
dass es hier um ein völlig getrenntes
verfahren e
das auch noch viel weiter in die zukunft
weist
aber auch dieses verfahren wirft
verschiedene unterschiedliche fragen auf
also damit würde der putin in einer
reihe stehen mit etlichen
kriegsverbrechern insbesondere jetzt aus
dem kosovo krieg die sich alle
ja verantworten mussten
vielleicht mal ein kleiner hinweis
vorweg sie wurden zum special advisor
für den chef ermittler ernannt was ist
da ihre aufgabe der ankläger des
internationalen
gerichtshofs verfügt über eine reihe von
sogenannten special advisor im
kern geht es darum dass er sich auch von
außen unter umständen wissenschaftlichen
sachverstand bei seiner arbeit zu nutze
machen will da geht es natürlich im
grundsatz
allgemeinere eben grundsätzlichere
rechts fragen die sich stellen nicht um
das operative tagesgeschäft
die aufgaben sind verteilt nach
bestimmten sachgebieten mein portfolio
also insofern bin ich nicht allgemein
special advisor sondern mein portfolio
ist begrenzt auf das
verbrechen der aggression auf das war
sicherlich gleich noch zu sprechen
kommen und zu diesem verbrechen berate
ich den chef ankläger so er es wünscht
genau das um das vielleicht noch mal
deutlich machen sie können natürlich
deswegen auch überhaupt nicht inhaltlich
stellung nehmen zu irgendwelchen
ermittlungen die gerade laufen aber wir
schätzen sie natürlich da auch als
wertvollen
gesprächspartner
ganz generell zu diesem prozedere das
vermittlungsverfahren wurde ja schon
eingeleitet reicht auch zurück bis zum
jahr 2014 also zu dem angriff auf un und
die annexion der krim jetzt hat es
insofern eine neue entwicklung gegeben
als das auch da wieder auf betreiben der
ukraine ein antrag gestellt wurde hier
die ermittlung zu erwarten und diesem
antrag haben sich ja auch etliche
staaten angeschlossen
was ist das für ein procedere ja wobei
genau genommen die ukraine hier gar
nichts mehr erweitern musste die ukraine
ist das haben sie völlig richtig
angedeutet schon tätig geworden
vielleicht noch mal etwas
grundsätzlicher zum ausgangspunkt auch
für den internationalen strafgerichtshof
stellen sich zu beginn eines verfahrens
immer zuständigkeitsfragen die sind
anderer art als beim internationalen
gerichtshof das haben sie sehr genau und
richtig unterschieden aber es sind auch
sehr wichtige fragen und die sind in
diesem fall
auch durchaus kompliziert weil weder
russland noch die ukraine
vertragsparteien des gründungsvertrag
des internationalen strafgerichtshof
sind und weil aus gründen die auf der
hand liegen der sicherheitsrat
daran gehindert ist wegen der russischen
stellung dort die situation dem
internationalen strafgerichtshof zu
unterwerfen so was hat die ukraine dann
getan aber eben schon vor vielen jahren
sie hat sie sehen daran die die ukraine
war schon vor jahren sehr sehr agil in
dieser hinsicht das ist also nicht jetzt
erst eine beobachtung die wir in diesen
tagen machen die ukraine hat eine
möglichkeit genutzt die dieser
gründungsvertrag vorsieht für sogenannte
nicht
vertragsstaaten ich nenne hier mal eine
bestimmung artikel 12 absatz 3 des
jetzigen status und hat durch eine
spezifische
unterwerfungserklärung die zuständigkeit
des strafgerichtshofs eröffnet das hatte
sie in einer ersten
unterwerfungserklärung zeitlich begrenzt
getan und dann eine zweite
unterwerfungserklärung hinterher
geschoben und die ist zeitlich in die
zukunft offen und damit hatte der
internationale strafgerichtshof in
gestalt der vorgängerin des jetzigen
anklägers
bereits die möglichkeit ermittlungen
aufzunehmen und das hat die
seinerzeitige anklägerin getan und zwar
im hinblick auf
verdachtsmomente auf der von russland
besetzten krim und im hinblick auf
verdachtsmomente in der ost ukraine von
der wir wissen dass dort schon sehr
lange ein
konflikt unter russischer beteiligung
toben und diese
vorermittlungen im technischen sinn die
waren noch vor der amtsübernahme des
gegenwärtigen anklägers schon sehr weit
gediehen nämlich bis zu dem punkt dass
die seinerzeitige anklägerin
festgestellt hatte ich bin nun
eigentlich bereit die eröffnung eines
förmlichen
ermittlungsverfahrens zu beantragen ist
bestehen im hinblick auf die ost ukraine
verdachtsmomente erheblicher
kriegsverbrechen im hinblick auf die
krim ebenfalls erhebliche
verdachtsmomente von kriegsverbrechen
und darüber hinaus verdachtsmomente im
hinblick auf ein verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit es kam dann zu dem antrag
auf eröffnung noch nicht
das hatte zwei gründe die
seinerzeitige anklägerin wollte es mit
blick auf den bevorstehenden
amtswechsel dem neuen ankläger
überlassen die entscheidung zu treffen
und zweitens und das ist jetzt ein ganz
wichtiger allgemeiner punkt gab es
zunächst auch die frage mit blick auf
die ja notorisch begrenzten ressourcen
des internationalen strafgerichtshofs
ist es unter dem gesichtspunkt der
priorisierung sinnvoll dieses verfahren
zu eröffnen also die knappen ressourcen
dort einzusetzen das war die situation
die der ankläger vorfand als
russlands ein angriff begann und er hat
dann zwei schritte getan er hat in einem
ersten schritt unter dem
eindruck dieser dramatischen ereignisse
erklärt er werde nun
die möglichkeit die ihm seine
vorgängerin gewissermaßen vermacht hat
von dieser möglichkeit werde er nach
überprüfung der aktenlage nun gebrauch
machen er werde einen antrag auf
eröffnung eines förmlichen
ermittlungsverfahrens beantragen bei den
richtern und jetzt und in dieser
situation gegen alles sehr sehr schnell
jetzt kam dieser schritt den sie
angesprochen haben und das ist
jedenfalls dem umfang nach ein präsident
loser schritt dann haben sich 39 staaten
so jedenfalls meine letzte information
39 staaten unter dem eindruck des
russischen angriffs dazu entschlossen
ihrerseits als vertragsstaaten dem
ankläger die situation ukraine zur
bearbeitung zu überweisen und das hatte
ich jetzt eine sehr gravierende
prozessuale
konsequenz nämlich die konsequenz dass
das bis zu diesem zeitpunkt notwendig
erscheinende gerichtliche verfahren
artikel 15 absatz 3 absatz 4 erste ghs
tattoos entfernen konnte weil jetzt
starten vertragsstaaten die eröffnung
beantragt hatten und nicht nur in
anführungszeichen der ankläger aus
eigener initiative und so konnte der
ankläger dann in einer weiteren
entscheidung die er der öffentlichkeit
bekannt gemacht hat erklären er habe die
er habe ein förmliches
ermittlungsverfahren
eröffnet das konnte er eben jetzt ohne
richterlich ermächtigung dies bezieht
sich frau beatrice nochmal zunächst
einmal im kern auf taten die in der
vergangenheit liegen aber ich sagte eben
die unterwerfungserklärung der ukraine
ist zeitlich nach vorne offen und so hat
der ankläger ist auch formuliert und
gesagt natürlich werde er nun auch die
die sich entwickelnden kampfhandlungen
genau oben genau darum geht es jetzt
quasi beweise zu sichten zu sichern zu
sammeln um irgendwann einmal in
ferner oder hoffentlich nicht so ferner
zukunft dann tatsächlich
so womöglich zu einer anklage zu kommen
bedeutet dass mal sehr konkret gefragt
dass wir den russischen präsidenten
wladimir putin auf der anklagebank sehen
werden irgendwann das wäre jetzt schon
wieder eine bemerkung oder eine eine
einlassung die zumal
mit blick auf die funktionen die ich
auch wahrnehme
zu weit ginge und zu konkret ging ich
schildere die rechtliche situation
so wie sie besteht und sie ist
dergestalt
dass der ankläger nach allen richtungen
ermitteln wird das ist sehr wichtig die
seine zuständigkeit ist bezogen auf die
situation der ukraine und damit fällt
alles was nun auch im moment geschieht
unter dem gesichtspunkt der
straftatbestände des dgh statuts mit
ausnahme des verbrechens der aggression
unter seine zuständigkeit zunächst ist
das sind das ermittlungen in die
situation insgesamt
und aus solchen ermittlungen in der
situation die noch nicht konkretisiert
sind auf bestimmte personen kann dann
bei entsprechenden verdachtsmomenten
können dann ermittlungen werden gegen
bestimmte personen ich füge 1 hinzu auf
der allgemeinen ebene es entspricht der
gesamtstrategie der anklagebehörde nicht
erst seit dieser situation sondern ganz
generell das augenmerk insbesondere zu
richten auf diejenigen mit mutmaßlichen
mutmaßlicher
hauptverantwortlich kite für die tat nun
die es geht
dann reden wir doch jetzt mal über die
straftatbestände die hier eine rolle
spielen könnten sie hatten es schon
erwähnt sie sind
zuständig sie sind beschäftigen sich
besonders mit der aggression mit der
sogenannten und das ist ja in der tat
auch etwas was einen hier sofort ins
auge springt weil es sich tatsächlich um
ein angriffskrieg handelt also man
sollte
wie ich nun mal bin denken das wäre
eigentlich kein problem mit der
aggression ist es aber doch oder ja
diese frage ist nur zu begründet frau
das in der tat die
generalversammlung kein geringeres organ
als die generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen hat in einer besonderen sitzung
in einer besonderen resolution
united for peace mit überwältigender
mehrheit
festgestellt und auf das schärfste
bedauert dass
russlands angriff eine aggression und
damit eben eine gravierende verletzung
des völkerrechtlichen gewalt verbots
darstellt und damit stellt sich
unweigerlich die frage
nach dem verbrechen der aggression denn
das verbrechen der aggression ist wenn
sie so möchten der straftatbestand der
der verhaltensnormen gewaltverbot die
sich an die staaten richtet daneben noch
eine strafrechtliche sanktion storm
hinzu fügt insofern steht tatsächlich
die frage nach dem aggressions
verbrechen in einer im raum dass
aggressions verbrechen allerdings und
jetzt kommt der entscheidende punkt sie
sagten ja schon so einfach ist das doch
nicht nein es ist sogar im gegenteil so
dass dem ankläger für den moment bis auf
weiteres die hände gebunden sind im
hinblick auf
dieses verbrechen zu ermitteln das hängt
damit zusammen dass sich die staaten im
hinblick auf das verbrechen der
aggression zu einer ganz besonders engen
regelung der zuständigkeit des
gerichtshofs des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs entschlossen haben das
wiederum liegt daran dass das verbrechen
der aggression für sehr viele staaten
und jetzt um das sehr deutlich zu machen
leider nicht nur russland sondern viele
staaten auch der westlichen welt als ein
ganz besonders politisch sensibles
verbrechen galt dem man sich mit
zurückhaltung genähert hat und es waren
vor allem die fünf ständigen mitglieder
des sicherheitsrats die in an dieser
stelle in schöner eintracht und da
gehören eben auch england und frankreich
als vertragsstaaten des statuts hinzu
sich für eine enge zuständigkeit
ausgesprochen haben die position dieser
staaten lautete für lange zeit im kern
ein strafverfahren wegen des verbrechens
der aggression soll es überhaupt nur
geben wenn der sicherheitsrat grünes
licht erteilen das hätte dann praktisch
bedeutet liegen werden was wir verwenden
das vetorecht eines ständigen mitglied
im raume steht am ende konnte in den
verhandlungen ein darüber hinausgehendes
zuständigkeits regime erreicht werden
aber das greift in diesem fall weil der
angriff von einem nicht vertragsstaat
russland aus geht eben auch nicht das
heißt ganz konkret der ankläger wird im
hinblick auf das verbrechen der
aggression und das ist höchst
bedauerlich so lange nicht tätig werden
können wie ihm von seiten des
sicherheitsrats der vereinten nationen
hierzu kein grünes licht geben genau und
das wird voraussichtlich niemals
passieren also man sieht dass da schon
in der vergangenheit auch unabhängig von
dieser krise von diesem krieg jetzt viel
schief gelaufen ist auch dass völker
recht bewusst sehr klein gehalten wurde
auch weil die westlichen staaten das
kann man auch mal so direkt sagen da
gemacht haben und jetzt womöglich wie
hier den preis dafür zahlen aber es gibt
ja noch andere straftatbestände der sg
was wenn ich noch ein ärzte dazu sagen
darf wenn sie mir das erlauben genau das
muss nicht das letzte wort den
geschichte sein also zunächst einmal was
den sicherheitsrat anbetrifft sie haben
jetzt recht locker gesagt das wird nie
passieren mit dem worten nie sollte man
in der internationalen politik
zurück
wir wissen auch nicht im hinblick auf
russland wie sich die situation
entwickelt und im hinblick auf den
strafgerichtshof mit seiner
zuständigkeit für das aggressions
verbrechen möchte ich jedenfalls diese
gelegenheit nutzen ist jetzt nicht nur
bei einem lamento zu belassen sondern
auch zu sagen was und zwar am morden
getan werden kann um die situation für
die zukunft zu bessern zum einen sollte
das verbrechen der aggression und hier
richte ich mich in der tat auch an die
westlichen staaten übrigens
eingeschlossen deutschland dass diese
entwicklung sehr befördert hat das will
ich sehr lobend sagen dieses verbrechen
der aggression und den umstand dass ist
im bsd ghs da tut nicht nur steht
sondern dass die zuständigkeit
inzwischen aktiviert worden ist diesen
zustand nicht länger tot zu schweigen es
gab noch im letzten jahr eine erklärung
des außenbeauftragten der europäischen
union
der zählte die verbrechens tatbestände
die der stadt unterfallen auf aber das
verbrechen der aggression kam ich konnte
meinen ohren nicht trauen nicht vor
dieser dieser
besser maßen diese geisteshaltung das
verbrechen der aggression weil es
politisch sensibel weil es unbequem ist
tot zu schweigen die sollte sich ändern
und da hätte auch die deutsche
völkerrechts politik eine ganz wichtige
und verdienstvolle aufgabe oder rolle zu
spielen und der zweite punkt die
vertragsstaaten sind aufgerufen
die
vertragsveränderungen die den
gerichtshof in die lage versetzt haben
seine zuständigkeit über das verbrechen
der aggression
auszuüben diese vertragsänderungen zu
ratifizieren beziehungsweise ihnen
beizutreten dazu braucht es überhaupt
kein neues völkerrecht sondern es
braucht nur den entsprechenden
politischen willen den hätte man es wäre
sehr schön gewesen den hätten viele die
ihn noch nicht gebildet haben schon
früher gebildet aber jedenfalls jetzt
meine sollte doch jedem klar sein wie
bedeutsam auch diese facette des statuts
des internationalen strafgerichtshof ist
und erstatten sie mir noch eine letzte
bemerkung es ist ja im
zusammenhang mit
russland
jetzt in etwas grösseren kontext
auch gerade von putin und seinem
propaganda apparat
geschürt die rede davon von westlichen
fremden ideen die operiert würden gegen
die man sich wehren müsse das verbrechen
der aggression ist erwachsen aus dem
nürnberger
straftatbestand des verbrechens gegen
den frieden und jetzt verbindet man mit
der geburtsstunde des völkerstrafrechts
dem nürnberger prozess vor allem die
vereinigten staaten vor allem den
charismatischen chef ankläger robert
jackson dabei wird vergessen dass
gerade im hinblick auf das heutige
verbrechen der aggression den damaligen
straftatbestand des verbrechens gegen
den frieden es die russische seite war
die auf dieses verfahren gedrängt tanzen
und mehr noch auch das ist heute wenig
bekannt den namen verbrechen gegen den
frieden das muss man sich heute auf der
zunge zergehen lassen der den verdanken
wir der ist in das statut des nürnberger
militär gerichtshofs gekommen durch
einen russischen völkerrechts lehrer mit
dem namen aaron
das ist eine besondere ironie der
geschichte aber kommt doch jetzt nochmal
zu dem was sich tatsächlich wie möglich
verwirklicht und auch
womöglich einfacher nachweisen lässt
nämlich die kriegsverbrechen bzw die
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
viele haben ihr urteil schon gefällt sie
sind sicher dass putin ein
kriegsverbrecher ist die zerbombten
wohnblöcke krankenhäuser dass in staaten
flammen stehende atomkraftwerk sind er
nun jeden abend in den nachrichten also
wie eindeutig ist das tatsächlich also
auch da wieder eine vorverurteilung ist
natürlich in diesem zusammenhang
schwierig aber sind das gibt es genug
hinweise darauf oder viren dass solche
kriegsverbrechen und wie schwierig wird
die beweisführung ja fangen wir
vielleicht
einmal bei der frage schwierigkeit der
beweisführung mit einer allgemeinen
bemerkung an
diese ermittlungen soweit sie nun den
laufenden konflikt betreffen diese
ermittlungen stehen da soll man sich und
darf man sich nichts vormachen eben vor
dieser besonderen herausforderung
dass sie während eines laufenden
konflikt erfolgen und da sind die
möglichkeiten
des zugriffs der ermittler eingeschränkt
wenn sie in die geschichte der
entwicklung des völkerstrafrechts
zurückgehen dann werden sie feststellen
dass über lange jahrzehnte es so war
dass die völker strafrechtliche arbeit
im kern die förmlichen ermittlungen erst
begonnen haben nach dem abschluss des
konflikts nehmen sie vor allem den
zweiten weltkrieg aber nehmen sie auch
die wiedergeburt wenn ich das so sagen
darf des völkerstrafrechts in den 1990
er jahren die balkanischen
konflikte ruander da hat der
sicherheitsrat die tribunale eingesetzt
und die haben ihre arbeit begonnen zu
einem zeitpunkt als das eigentliche das
ganz heiße konflikt geschehen bereits im
wesentlichen abgeschlossen war das hat
sich jetzt im hinblick auf den
internationalen
strafgerichtshof der ja nun eben der
erste ständige internationale
strafgerichtshof der rechtsgeschichte
ist geändert und im ausgangspunkt ist
das sehr zu begrüßen denn diesem
internationalen strafgerichtshof haftet
jetzt nicht mehr der oben eines
sondergerichts an das rückwirkend tätig
wird mit seinen ermittlungen mit blick
auf bestimmte situationen sondern die
zuständigkeit des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs die ist bereits davor
der tat und deshalb ist das jetzt auch
nicht der erste konflikt in der noch
jungen geschichte des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs in dem
die
anklagebehörde mit
ermittlungsarbeiten beginnt während ein
konflikt noch heiß ist das waren bisher
überwiegend nicht internationale
bewaffnete konflikte interne konflikte
aber im hinblick auf die
herausforderungen die sich den
ermittlern stellen eben insbesondere
nicht vor ort tätig werden zu können und
sei es auch nur durch rechtshilfe mit
den staaten ist das ein problem das
selbe dennoch es ist gut und wichtig und
hilfreich
dass die ermittlungen in dem maße in dem
das jetzt möglich ist durch auswertung
öffentlich zugänglicher quellen
möglicherweise werden die staaten mit
informationen behilflich sein können zu
beginnen und denken sie auch die an
dieser stelle noch einmal in die
geschichte zurück
die entscheidung den nürnberger
militärgerichtshof
einzusetzen die ist in form des londoner
abkommens erst nach dem ende des krieges
getroffen worden aber die entscheidung
zur strafverfolgung des sie fiel im
krieg und im krieg bereits wurde
eingesetzt die united nations war crimes
commission die eben begann mit der
sammlung von informationen für den
zeitpunkt danach also in embryonaler
form gab es diese dinge die wir jetzt
erleben damals auch also sie zur
vielleicht zur
prozeduralen situation und jetzt haben
sie nach dem materiellen recht gefragt
wie machen wirst es war ihre zweite
richtig dass da ging es eben konkret
davon die der angriff auf zivilisten die
wohnblöcke dieter bomben wohnblöcke das
ist schon etwas wo der fluss hier liegen
kriegsverbrechen vor relativ nah ist
oder ja das zielt diese problematik
zählt jetzt auf eine kardinal normen des
geltenden kriegsrechts und vielleicht
auch an dieser stelle nochmal damit wir
ganz klar die dinge gedanklich
sortierung und vor augen halten eine
vorbemerkung wir haben eben vom
völkerrechtlichen gewaltverbot
gesprochen und dem aggressions oder dem
tatbestand des verbrechens der
aggression das auf das gewaltverbot
bezogen ist jetzt geht es um ein anderes
wichtiges teilgebiet der völker
rechtsordnung wir sprechen heute vom
völkerrecht der bewaffneten konflikte
früher hat man kriegsrecht gesagt
völkerrechtler bewachen konflikte oder
vielfach auch humanitäres völkerrecht
genannt und während es beim gewaltverbot
um das ob des gewalt einsatzes geht geht
es kurz gesprochen beim völkerrecht der
bewachen konflikte um das wie das
völkerrecht der bewaffneten konflikte
nimmt den traurigen zustand
dass es zu einem konflikt gekommen ist
an und versucht das ist die regelung
intention dieses rechtsgebiets den
schrecken der unweigerlich mit einem
solchen konflikt verbunden ist dann
immerhin in gewissen grenzen zu halten
aus dem übergeordneten gesichtspunkt der
humanität und eine zentrale regel dieser
dieses rechtsgebiets die haben sie an
der brauchen und die betrifft die
sogenannten kampfhandlungen also das
kerngeschehen des konflikts im
englischen conductor postille dies und
die elementare wege der internationale
gerichtshof spricht von einem kardinal
im prinzip die lautet gezielte angriffe
auf zivilisten
die haben unter allen umständen
kategorisch zu unterbleiben und dazu
gehören natürlich auch
gezielte angriffe auf zivile bewohnte
wie der name es schon sagt wohnhäuser
und sie haben einen zweiten punkt in
diesem zusammenhang angesprochen der ja
auch sehr aktuell ist die frage der
sogenannten
humanitären
korridore
dass diese figur der humanitären
korridore es gibt im kriegsrecht dafür
unterschiedliche begriffe aber das ist
eine wie wir ja auch in diesen tagen
sehen eine einrichtung von elementarer
wichtigkeit
humanitärer wichtigkeit humanitäre
korridore werden
eingerichtet typischerweise mit der
zustimmung der konfliktparteien
aus zwei gründen die kumulativ oder
alternativ verfolgt werden können zum
einen um medizinische und humanitäre
versorgung
zu ermöglichen gerade dann wenn die
auseinandersetzung quasi
belagerung scri gerissen züge annimmt im
hinblick des ringens um die einnahme von
städten und zum zweiten und auch das
sehen wir ja jetzt
täglich höchst angespannt wenn wir das
konflikt geschehen verfolgen der versuch
unter umständen
zivilisten aus belagerten städten zu
evakuieren um sie aus dieser ganz akuten
verzweifelten notlage zu befreien ein
solcher humanitärer korridor ist daneben
nur dann kann er funktionieren mit einer
sogenannten waffenruhe cease fire im
englischen verbunden das ist zu trennen
von einem waffenstillstand das wäre ein
anspruchsvolleres regime eine solche
waffenruhe cease fire ist zeitlich
räumlich eng begrenzt alles hängt vom
konsens der parteien ab der von außen
vermittelt sein kann vom sicherheitsrat
wäre er handlungsfähig auch angeregt
werden könnte um dient also diesen
beiden schutz elementen wenn es nun hier
im zuge einer solchen
vereinbarten und ich spreche jetzt
abstrakt frau bruders nie mit blick auf
das konkret geschehen wenn es im zuge
einer solchen evakuierung
etwa zu bombardierungen von
zivilisten aus der luft kommt dann ist
das man möchte fast sagen ein ganz
besonders infam
kriegsverbrechen denn hier wird dann
zusätzlich noch das zuvor in anspruch
genommene vertrauen missbraucht und
dieses vertrauen ist ein wie sie sich
denken können höchst fragiles gut in
einer situation
wie einem bewaffneten konflikt herr
professor presse also wir sehen selbst
in so einer schwierigen situation gibt
es eigentlich grundregeln kardinal
regeln gesetz formuliert haben an sich
die die sich die konflikt parteien
halten sollten wir sehen wirklich mit
bestürzen dass es nicht so ist das war
in diesen eindruck möchte ich jetzt mal
so formulieren aber ich danke ihnen sehr
herzlich dass sie uns so ausführlich die
situation erläutert haben schöne grüße
nach köln hätte es ja gerne
ja also das war das interview mit klaus
crestor einer wirklich ziemlich schweren
und komplizierten materie und so geht es
auch gleich weiter wir gucken auf das
russische zensurgesetz das neue gesetz
ging
falschinformationen über die russischen
streitkräfte
sowie es in russland heißt wurde am
vergangenen freitag im eilverfahren
verabschiedet und von präsident wladimir
putin unterzeichnet und danach in kraft
getreten und das ist jetzt auf der einen
seite schlimm genug weil die
journalistinnen und journalisten im land
damit praktisch nicht mehr arbeiten
können aber es hat nach allem was man
jetzt bisher so hört offenbar auch
komplett wirkung für alle
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
die im land sind und das heißt ja
vermutlich auch für die
korrespondentinnen der faz oder ja das
ist nur so wir hatten zwei
korrespondenten in russland katharina
wagner und friedrich schmidt die jetzt
tatsächlich sehr überstürzt das land
verlassen mussten wie auch viele andere
komponenten also addieren zdf haben
gesagt dass sie ihre korrespondenten
abziehen auch internationale medien cnn
bloomberg news ich meine auch die bbc
haben gesagt und der diesen umständen
können sie eben einerseits für ihre
komponenten nicht
garantieren können sich für den schutz
ihrer korrespondenten garantieren und
das ist natürlich zentral für die arbeit
der verlagshäuser und letztendlich ist
natürlich auch hier die pressefreiheit
so sehr in gefahr dass man gar nicht
mehr davon ausgehen kann dass da
irgendetwas
wahrheitsgetreu es noch aus russland
berichtet werden kann genau wenn man
also einen krieg nicht mehr als krieg
bezeichnen darf dann sind halt alle
berichte berichterstattung möglichkeiten
im prinzip auf null reduziert ja genau
also das ist ja exakt der zentrale punkt
dass die der krieg in der ukraine nicht
mehr als krieg bezeichnet werden darf
sondern nur noch als spezialoperationen
die angeblich auf eine
entnazifizierung des
der ukraine zählt was natürlich wirklich
einfach unglaublich hohen und zynismus
spiegelt aber
so ist es eben leider und es wendet sich
eben auch gegen die ausländischen
korrespondenten
das ist kern der ganzen geschichte die
jetzt seit vergangenen freitag in kraft
tritt und ich kann da verweisen auf
einen artikel den unser korrespondent
fröhlich mit der jetzt eben nicht mehr
in russland ist sondern der hat es nicht
nach deutschland in deutschland weit
aber eben von da aus von hier aus
natürlich so weit es geht bericht weiter
berichtet wir wären natürlich da die
augen aufhalten und er schrieb heute das
erste redaktion auch schon am samstag
durchsucht wurden also sozusagen
stehenden fußes hat die regierung haben
dann auch die
ermittlungsbehörden die arbeit
aufgenommen und sie schon 144 menschen
festgenommen und eine reihe von
bußgeldern verhängt das ist natürlich
irgendwie einfach ganz besonders bitter
wenn man auch sieht also wie absurde
züge das annähert geschrieben zum
beispiel von einer frau die eine
einzelne mahnwache abgehalten hat und
damit ein bußgeld belangt wurde ein
priester in einer predigt den hat auch
getroffen eine frau hat im schnee
geschrieben nein zum krieg und auch sie
hat ein bußgeld bekommen also all das
sind böse vorworten auf das was jetzt
auch in russland noch passieren wird
aber nun wenn wir unseren blick mal nach
deutschland dem papier also jetzt sind
ja wirklich etliche ukrainer und
ukrainerinnen hier schon ins land
gekommen ist und heute über zwei
millionen laune hatte er sind es schon
über zwei millionen menschen auf der
flucht und hier in deutschland ungefähr
60.000 plus soweit also stand gestern wo
60.000 plus ganz so sicher und bekannt
ist das alles gar nicht weil die gar
nicht alle zwingend registriert werden
müssen
nach medienmeldungen die auch noch nicht
wirklich von offizieller seite bestätigt
sind sind es wohl ganz überwiegend
frauen und kinder die hier einreisen was
natürlich sinn ergibt weil die männer im
wehrpflichtigen alter die ukraine ja gar
nicht verlassen dürfen und dieses
wehrpflichtige alter ist ja sehr weit
definiert nämlich von 18 bis 60 jahre
das heißt also alles spricht dafür dass
die bisherigen medienmeldungen stimmen
und arbeit gehen frauen und kinder
reinkommen reinkommen heißt in
deutschland nun weit kleinerer teil du
hast es gerade schon gesagt corinna denn
die meisten der geflüchteten sind und
bleiben erstmal in polen es gibt noch
keine offiziellen prognosen dazu mit wie
vielen geflüchteten mann eigentlich
rechnet also da hält sich auch das
innenministerium zum beispiel sehr
zurück es weiß ja auch keiner wie genau
sich dieser krieg weiterentwickelt aber
migrationsforscher gehen davon aus dass
es bis zu zehn millionen menschen werden
können die da aus der ukraine insgesamt
flüchten werden und bis zu vielleicht
225.000 in deutschland lampen werden
sozusagen auf jeden fall hat das alles
ausgereicht damit in wirklich seltener
einigkeit und schnelligkeit die
europäische und nun also der rat der
europäischen union in der vergangenen
woche die richtlinie zur gewährung
vorübergehenden schutzes aktiviert hat
die sogenannten massenzustrom richtlinie
ich finde das ist ja ein sehr
merkwürdiges wort irgendwie noch was
nicht so richtig danach klingt was es
ist denn es geht tatsächlich darum dass
sehr viele menschen vorübergehend schutz
bekommen sofort und kollektiv für alle
die von der richtlinie erfasst werden
ohne dass im einzelfall geprüft wird und
das gilt in allen mitgliedstaaten der
union ja und darüber haben wir ja auch
schon mit helene vergangene woche
gesprochen da waren sie sozusagen noch
im vorbereitungsstadium aber der war
schon einiges klar das ganze ist jetzt
tatsächlich am donnerstag beschloss
austin war worden und was hat das nun
für auswirkungen für deutschland und wie
wird das ganze umgesetzt also was
erwartet die menschen hier
darüber habe ich gesprochen mit dr
matthias lehnert der matthias ist
rechtsanwalt für asyl und
aufenthaltsrecht in leipzig und wie ich
schon aus langen jahren weiß immer sehr
gut informiert und mit dem habe ich eben
vor der sendung gesprochen der hat mir
der rede und antwort zu den fragen
gestanden ich habe mir nämlich vor allem
erst mal gefragt für wen gilt denn das
jetzt eigentlich und da kam dann heute
morgen noch das update oder quasi
genauer gesagt gestern abend da gab es
nämlich eine neue verordnung denn es
stand in der richtlinie von anfang an
war das klar dass diese richtlinie gilt
also dieser schutz gilt für alle
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer und die
familienangehörigen das ergibt sich
direkt aus der richtlinie es war aber
streitig und es ist auch auf eu ebene
immer noch nicht ganz geklärt was
eigentlich mit anderen menschen ist die
aus der ukraine kommen also vor allem
drittstaatsangehörige das heißt nicht
ukraine die aber in der ukraine gelebt
haben
und das wurde erst jetzt tatsächlich
gestern geklärt das wurde nämlich auf
nationaler ebene geklärt und deutschland
ist da über das hinausgegangen was auf
eu-ebene beschlossen wurde und jetzt
wurde auf deutscher ebene geklärt per
verordnung dass auch alle
drittstaatsangehörigen das heißt alle
menschen die in der ukraine lebten am 24
februar erst mal nach deutschland
einreisen dürfen das sind eben zum
beispiel flüchtlinge die in der ukraine
gerät haben also vor allem laut matthias
lehnert sind das oppositionelle aus
belarus zum beispiel es gibt aber wohl
auch einige flüchtlinge aus afghanistan
oder dem iran die in der ukraine waren
und auch diese menschen dürfen jetzt
erstmal einreisen neben flüchtlingen
betrifft das auch sehr sehr viele
studierende es gab für so um die 75 76
1000 ausländische studierende die in der
ukraine studiert haben und das ging auch
bei twitter relativ stark rum darunter
auch viele people of colour die dann
wohl an den polnischen grenzen erst mal
nicht reingelassen wurden und so also da
gab es wohl erst mal relativ viel ärger
jetzt steht aber zumindest für
deutschland fest die dürfen auch erstmal
hier einreisen ohne irgendwas ohne visum
die dürfen allerdings nur dann erst mal
für drei monate bleiben dasselbe gilt
auch für menschen dass wir auch noch
streitig bis gestern das war auch unklar
die schon vor dem 24 februar aus der
ukraine gekommen sind also die quasi
schon dass das elend ein bisschen
vorausgesehen haben die diesen angriff
vorausgesehen haben und vor dem 24
februar ein gekommen sind das war auch
noch unklar da hat stellt die deutsche
verordnung jetzt klar auch für die gilt
dass die können jetzt hier alle erstmal
einreisen und sich hier illegal
aufhalten
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer für die gilt
das ohnehin die dürfen sowieso alle die
ohne visum hier einreisen und sich 90
tage legal hier aufhalten und das ist
auch so ein bisschen der grund dafür
dass hatte die bundesinnenministerium
nennt sie phaser am wochenende auch
schon gesagt dass nicht alle menschen
hier quasi irgendwo gelistet sind denn
es gibt im moment keine grenzkontrollen
oder so was zumindest nicht offiziell
sondern die dürfen eben einfach
reinkommen weil die eben biometrische
pässe haben und die dürfen sich in
deutschland völlig unabhängig von diesem
krieg von diesem angriff für 90 tage
immer legal aufhalten so nur deshalb
gibt es nicht zwingend listen genau also
das ist vielleicht auch eine
sondersituation zu dem was wir vorher
gesehen zu der großen flüchtlingswelle
2015 wo ihr tatsächlich auch viele von
außerhalb der eu kamen nun ist die
ukraine natürlich auch kein bestandteil
der eu aber es gab schon länger eben
diese erleichterten visums
regularien also die 90 tage galten auch
schon vorher nun ist ja darüber hinaus
einen 90 tagen wird sehr wahrscheinlich
nicht getan sein in drei monaten wäre ja
sehr schön wenn diese krise wenn der
krieg dann vorbei wäre und das land
wieder sicher wäre aber es geht ja noch
darüber hinaus genau es geht ja auch
nicht nur um die dauer sondern dann darf
man eben als ukrainerin oder ukraine
einfach hier einreisen 90 tage bleiben
aber dann hat man zum beispiel auch
keinen zugang zu sozialleistungen oder
keinen anspruch darauf irgendwo
unterzukommen oder so das ist ja die
ganz normale regelung und jetzt bekommen
die ukrainerin und der ukraine die jetzt
hier einreisen kein asylrecht
vorübergehen in den schutzstatus das ist
der paragraph 24 aufenthaltsgesetz das
ist also eine offizielle
aufenthaltserlaubnis dieser 24
aufenthaltsgesetz der setzt ist quasi
die nationale norm die diese richtlinie
umsetzt das heißt die ukrainerin dürfen
hier einfach bleiben ohne
grenzkontrollen ohne irgendwas und zwar
erstmal für ein jahr danach kann die
richtlinie verlängert werden das ganze
gilt jetzt aber erstmal für ein jahr
etwas anders ist es das ist jetzt das
steht jetzt eben fest seit diese
verordnung da gestern raus kam für die
ausländerinnen und ausländer die in der
ukraine gelebt haben also geflüchtete
studierende usw die dürfen auch
visumsfrei einreisen und sich erst mal
egal auf hand aufhalten das gilt
allerdings erst mal nur bis mai dieses
jahres und die kriegen jetzt auch noch
keine aufenthaltserlaubnis das scheint
offenbar noch nicht klar zu sein was wie
es mit denen jetzt weitergeht denn es
gibt natürlich auch jetzt national
stimmen die sagen moment mal aber in
deren heimatland herrscht ja keinen
krieg also wir können die ja jetzt erst
mal gerne hier aufnehmen aber wie es
dann weitergeht ist noch nicht klar also
man kann ja jetzt schon sagen dass ein
studierender keine ahnung irgendwo auf
einem afrikanischen staat muss man dem
jetzt ermöglichen dass der hier in der
eu sein studium fortsetzt oder muss der
dann nach hause das scheint tatsächlich
noch nicht geklärt zu sein es steht aber
fest dass die erst mal zumindest keinen
aufenthaltstitel kriegen das bedeutet
jetzt natürlich nicht nicht dass diese
menschen dann irgendwie schutzlos wären
sondern zum beispiel jemand der ein
anerkannter flüchtling in der ukraine
war der kann natürlich auch hier in
deutschland dann ein asylantrag stellen
aber er hat eben jetzt nicht so ein
kollektiv schutz und das heißt nicht
einfach irgendwie du kannst erst mal
hier bleiben wie zum beispiel es ihm bei
den ukraine an die ukraine aber um das
deutlich zu machen also diejenigen für
die die sache geklärt ist die jetzt
diesen oft als titel für die nächsten
drei jahre haben die kein ja erst mal
ein jahr und dann kann es verlängert
werden und die können sich aber frei
bewegen hier also das heißt sie können
sich niederlassen wo sie wollen was
heißt es denn für die diskussionen die
jetzt zum beispiel von franziska giffey
also unserer neuen bürgermeisterin in
berlin angestoßen wurde die gesagt hat
'jetzt sind sehr sehr viele leute hier
in berlin die müssen verteilt werden
kann man dieser menschen eigentlich
überhaupt verteilen oder können sie sich
nicht aussuchen wo sie sein wollen alles
noch total unklar stand jetzt ist jetzt
dass die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sich
aussuchen dürfen wo sie sein möchten und
das gilt erstmal auf der eu ebene also
das heißt das dublin-verfahren wird
nicht angewandt normalerweise muss man
ja in dem land irgendwie ein antrag auf
schutz stellen indem man als erstes die
eu betritt das gilt nicht im moment gilt
das prinzip die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer können sich das selber
aussuchen in welchem land sie sein
wollen denn ist zum beispiel sehr viele
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sagen ja auch
sie möchten zum beispiel gar nicht nach
deutschland sondern sie möchten in polen
bleiben einfach aus diesem gefühl der
räumlichen nähe da sagen meine
verwandten sind noch in der ukraine ich
möchte gar nicht nach deutschland und so
weit weg natürlich muss man abwarten wie
das weitergeht denn wenn polen jetzt
völlig überlastet ist und dieser zustrom
nicht aufhört vielleicht ändert sich
dieses friedhofs verfahren noch mal
stand heute die dürfen aber erst mal
wohin sie wollen so auf nationaler ebene
wenn die in deutschland ankommen dann
haben diese geflüchteten im moment auch
das recht darauf sich aus zu suchen wo
sie leben wollen
also es ist so dass man das sie in
anspruch auf eine unterkunft haben sie
können aber auch bei freunden und
familie unterkommen und laut matthias
lehnert klingt ist wohl derzeit so als
ob es eine verteilung geben soll
zwischen den ländern wie bei
asylverfahren aber nur dann wenn die
leute nicht siehst sich selbst quasi
unter player also wenn die nicht
irgendwo unterkommen bei freunden oder
familie das heißt nur für die menschen
die die nicht ein anlaufpunkt haben soll
es eine regelung geben wie die aber
aussehen soll ist bisher wohl noch
vollkommen also es gibt überhaupt noch
kein verteilungsschlüssel oder so sehr
voll sind halt im moment berlin und wohl
auch hamburg ist werden ja auch schon
viele geflüchtete nach nrw gebracht wir
nehmen auch schon relativ viele auf im
moment aber es gibt noch überhaupt keine
regelung dazu und es gibt eben auch noch
keine finanzierungs absprachen bislang
halten sich da alle noch sehr bedeckt
und die diskussion zwischen dem bund und
den ländern brechen schon los natürlich
aber auch mit den kommunen und die denn
die kommunen sind diejenigen die das
jetzt erstmal alles vorbereiten und
erstmal alles schultern müssen alles
noch völlig unklar es gibt überhaupt
noch kein zu sagen dazu wie viel der
bund davon übernehmen wird und so war ja
das ist schon eine unglaubliche mammut
aufgaben und ja wir leben die jetzt also
das erste ist dass das natürlich sehr
viele kinder jetzt mit kommen unter
anderem auch unbegleitete kinder also es
gibt wohl sehr viele ukrainerinnen die
nicht nur die eigenen kinder mitbringen
sondern auch die kinder von nachbarn von
freunden von familie und für die ist
klar dass die hier zur schule gehen
dürfen die haben anspruch darauf zur
schule zu gehen da ist es wohl
bundesweit jetzt so dass die schulen
versuchen klassen aufzustellen wo
deutsch als fremdsprache unterrichtet
wird das gibt's ja auch nicht zwingend
überall und die erwachsenen dürfen wohl
auch arbeiten also es steht überall im
moment so ein bisschen ominös man dürfe
selbstständig tätig werden angestellte
tätigkeit müsse aber erlaubt werden das
dürfte vermutlich aus dem 24
aufenthaltsgesetz kommen dann steht das
ungefähr so drin laut matthias lehnert
ist das aber nicht so sondern er sagt
wenn man eine aufenthaltserlaubnis hat
in der nichts drinsteht dann darf man
allgemein arbeiten auch als angestellter
oder angestellte also matthias lehnert
sagte das könnte wohl eingeschränkt
werden aber derzeit sehr wohl alles
danach aus als würde das vollumfänglich
erlaubt werden ist natürlich auch sehr
sinnvoll denn selbst christian lindner
hat ja schon gesagt na ja also diese
flüchtlingswelle ist ja nicht
vergleichbar sondern die ukraine sind
natürlich sehr gut ausgebildet und ich
meine im weltweiten fachkräftemangel
macht ja deutschland auch keinen
unterschied und eigentlich ist man ja
froh wenn man dann diese gut
ausgebildeten ukraine und ukrainer hat
und die natürlich auch arbeiten gehen
wird
[Musik]
weitere frage natürlich bekommen die
finanzielle unterstützung ja die
bekommen dann eben wie quasi normale
asylbewerber werden die unterstützt also
krankenversicherungen und da gibt es
eine bezuschussung und grundleistungen
das liegt so ein bisschen unter dem
hartz-iv-satz also das ist wirklich sehr
gering ein paar hundert euro und dann
habe ich matthias lehnert noch gefragt
wie lange gilt das jetzt diese
richtlinie ist wie gesagt erst mal für
ein jahr aktiviert und so lange besteht
auf der schutzstatus aller die darunter
fallen noch mal das gilt für die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer nicht für die
ausländer die in der ukraine gelegt
haben die haben jetzt erstmal nur diesen
diese drei monate da scheint so
auszusehen dass man sich dann noch mal
überlegen will was man macht dieses jahr
ist jetzt erst mal fix das verlängert
sich automatisch um ein weiteres jahr
wenn die eu da nichts anderes
beschließen würde und könnte sich wohl
noch mal um sechs monate verlängern ja
das ist natürlich am ende eine
politische entscheidung aber ich meine
wenn die ukraine in schutt und asche die
kann man sich schwer vorstellen dass
dass die politik das irgendwie schnell
aufheben würde ich würde sagen wir
können jetzt alle nur darauf hoffen dass
nicht erst in einem jahr die situation
so aussieht dass es keine verlängerung
geben muss vielleicht ist die ukraine ja
doch in den besseren zustand dass wir
das jetzt heute befürchten müssen es
scheint er zumindest mal erste signale
zu geben das jetzt auf allerhöchster
ebene die diplomatischen bemühungen
laufen also präsident zielinsky hat ja
obwohl gestern abend erstmalig gesagt
das ja nicht auf einem sofortigen
beitritt zur nato besteht und es ja aber
so ausruhen muss man ehrlich sagen also
ich weiß nicht ob man da viele
hoffnungen auf die derzeitigen
verhandlungen liegen kann so dramatisch
ist
naja wir werden sehen also das ist etwas
was ich ja von tag zu tag neu entwickelt
aber man kann sich natürlich schon
fragen warum das jetzt eigentlich diese
richtlinie so schnell aktiviert werden
konnte und sich da jetzt alle so einig
sind und dass 2015 so schwierig war aber
vielleicht kann man auch einfach mal
sich darüber freuen dass ich jetzt also
einig sind und das ja ja schon so
aufgenommen ehrlich gesagt ist die
antwort ja dass es eben gerade kein
praktikables und nachhaltiges verfahren
ist sondern der aus der
betroffenheit und aus der schnelligkeit
geboren ist ne das ist ja natürlich
jetzt das muss man ja hier bei aller
freude über die schnelle einigung
auch sagen es ist ja überhaupt gar keine
blaupause für künftige flüchtlingskrise
oder wie man überhaupt mit flüchtlingen
umgeht das ist ja ziemlich eindeutig
dass das hirn absolute sondersituation
ist für die menschen aus der ukraine
ja das ist auf jeden fall so ich weiß
gar nicht ob es nicht um nicht zumindest
eine bessere blaupause ist als das was
wir 2015 gesehen haben aber ich glaube
das kann man auch einfach nach nach 14
tagen jetzt noch nicht sagen
wie gesagt es gibt im moment keine
grenzkontrollen offiziell aber
inoffiziell gibt es wo doch wieder
grenznahe kontrollen und so die wohl
auch alle nicht so gut laufen wie sie
dann irgendwie eigentlich nicht laufen
sollten und so ist scheint schon alles
noch relativ chaotisch zu sein und ich
glaube vor allem auch diese ganzen
verteilungskämpfe die finanzierung ist
eben alles überhaupt noch nicht klar und
ich sage von daher muss man jetzt mal
abwarten wie es dann wirklich alles
ausgeht ich danke jedenfalls hier an
dieser stelle nochmal dr matthias
lehnert sehr der mich da gestern echt
sensationell auf den neuesten stand
gebracht hat vielen dank matthias
shoutout an dich
am mikrofon begrüße ich jetzt meine
kollegen marcus jung vielen hiervon ihn
ja auch bekannt als
gelegentlicher podcast aus markus schön
dass mal wieder dabei west
sprechen können ja wir wollen uns heute
mal die kanzleien zur brust nehmen und
da mal ganz genau gucken eigentlich die
verwicklungen und verstrickungen mit
russland sind das ist herrn sehr
interessante geschäftsbereich viele
kanzleien auch hier in deutschland aber
auch in den vereinigten staaten habe mir
enge kontakte geknüpft zu unternehmen
privatpersonen in russland wie sieht es
da aus markus ja wie du schon gesagt
hast nach dem zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion anfang der 1990 er jahre
sind ja sehr sehr viele
wirtschaftskanzleien sowohl nach
russland gegangen internationale als
auch das natürlich russische unternehmen
die expandiert sind oder geschäft
gemacht haben mit dem westen war vor
allem auch die oligarchen die sich dann
angesiedelt haben eigentum im ausland
erworben haben die mussten sich dann
auch hier ein rechtsrat suchen haben das
massiv natürlich getan durch
internationale aber auch deutschland als
kanzler
und es gab auch einige deutsche
großkanzleien die in den frühen 1990 er
jahren dann gerade im osteuropäischen
raum aber auch in russland sankt
petersburg und moskau vor allen dingen
groß auf und haben auch kiew und dadurch
haben wir natürlich zahlreiche deutsch
ukrainische aber auch deutsch russischen
wirtschaftsbeziehungen in denen auf
beiden seiten anwälte tätig sind die
ausgangssituation und da stellen sich
jetzt natürlich verschiedene fragen in
einer kriegssituation sondern
außergewöhnlichen situation darf man da
weiter beraten soll man dabei weiter
beraten kann man den mandanten
möglicherweise im sprichwörtlich regen
stehen lassen kann man sich aus den
mandaten lösen da ist eine sehr lebhafte
debatte entstanden und das wollen wir
jetzt mal ein bisschen aufdröseln man
kann ja einfach mal festhalten also die
anwälte haben natürlich auch über die
zeit gut verdient vielleicht können wir
mal uns genau angucken was sind denn das
eigentlich für mandate kannst du das ein
bisschen aufdröseln ich nehme an ein
paar oligarchen diese berühmten
oligarchen sind auch dabei da ging es
wahrscheinlich auch um so was wie
kaufverträge und so weiter und so fort
aber eben auch viele normale firmen
belangen ist es einerseits kann man
natürlich sagen dass es ein bisschen
einfacher glaube ich erst mal bei mir
über personen reden wie ein roman
abramowitsch dienst der vielen geläufig
ist durch sein engagement im bereich
profisport vor allen dingen als jetzt
dann bald ehemalige eigentümer von
chelsea fc in der unglaublich viel geld
investieren wie man so hört aus
medienberichten
alleine dieser verein schuldet
abramowitsch auf kreditbasis knapp 2 1
milliarden britische pfund die schuldet
der verein dem oligarchen also sein ja
ja ja ich wollte weil der entsprechend
natürlicher investiert hat und durch
diese finanzspritzen dann so ein
sportverein am leben hält kurzum das
sind im regelfall alles personen gewesen
die nach der privatisierung von
staatsunternehmen unglaublich schnell zu
viel geld und macht gekommen sind dieses
geld muss ja irgendwie investiert werden
oder auch ein etwas luxuriösen
lebensstil finanziert
werden das sind dann einfach eine gruppe
von personen die sehr nahe am
regierungsapparat standen sich dann
angesiedelt haben mit ihren familien in
westen sei es in der schweiz sei es an
der mittelmeerküste in in frankreich sei
es in südspanien oder vor allen dingen
london london hat ja den spitzen london
quatsch weil wir es dort vielen
ausländischen vermögenden über gründung
von sogenannten scherrer companies also
man nur auf deutsch sagen
briefkastenfirmen sehr einfach gemacht
wurde schnell geld anzulegen immobilien
zu kaufen in den mobilen zu investieren
das hat natürlich sehr sehr viele
genutzt da gibt es straßenzüge den quasi
keine einzige britischer staatsbürger
lebt man aber auch der anderen seite gar
nicht weiß wer da alles investiert ist
und lebt ja und das ist die eine seite
die pfeiltasten das andere sind
natürlich große
unternehmen was im bereich
energiewirtschaft telekommunikation aber
auch banken die ihr geschäft auf den
europäischen kontinent mit weiter
ausgebreitet haben expandiert haben von
der bankenseite her zwei bekannte namen
sind sicherlich die svr bank als auch
die vtb bank die auch teilweise in
deutschland aktiv sind um von der
energie seite da reden wir natürlich
über unternehmen wie rosneft wir in
europa gazprom die vielen von unseren
zuhören sicherlich bis vor ein paar
tagen bekannt waren als trikot-sponsor
von schalke 04
und da ist es ja nun die interessante
konstellation dass viele von den
unternehmen von den banken auch
natürlich von den energieunternehmen ja
mit den sanktionen belegt sind die die
eu vergangene woche verhängt hat aber
die kanzleien ist muss man so deutlich
sagen sind selber nicht betroffen oder
wie ist die lage dar also sind nicht
unmittelbar selbst betroffen wobei man
sicherlich unterscheiden muss wir haben
das maßnahmenpaket oder sage es ganz
paket der usa wir haben das mittlerweile
fünfte wenn ich mich nicht verzählt habe
maßnahmenpaket der eu und wir haben die
regelung die die briten getroffen haben
da würde ich gerne erstmal mit
einsteigen die dritten die ja natürlich
nicht mehr zur eu zählen und
entsprechend der prominenz dieser
personen die hier abends gezielt in
london da sehr harsch reagiert haben es
hat also auch dazu geführt dass dieses
thema der sogenannten oligarchen anwälte
oder weil die anwaltskanzlei die für
russische unternehmen und oligarchen
tätig sind sogar als bis ins britische
unterhaus
gebracht haben und zu einer debatte
geführt haben der sich auch der
britische premier ob boris johnson
beteiligte und er hat sinngemäß gesagt
als über diese kanzleien die haben
absolut verantwortlichkeiten in dieser
ganzen sache und es ist ganz klar wenn
sie sich dieser verantwortlichkeiten
zusammenhang mit sanktionen nicht
bewusst sind dann wird das für sie
konsequenzen haben denn wer in
großbritannien auf der liste der
sanktionierten unternehmen oder
sanktioniert werden privatpersonen steht
der ist natürlich einerseits wie soll
ich sagen geächtet und derjenige dann
der dann der berater von denen das muss
natürlich auch mit konsequenzen rechnen
und da hat sich dann die so genannte sae
das in der wettbewerbs werder war und
gleichzeitig eine aufsichtsbehörde die
vergleichbaren gewissen strukturen ist
mit der bundesrechtsanwaltskammer in
deutschland aber nicht 1 1 vergleichbar
sich auch positioniert und hat alle
anwaltskanzleien in großbritannien
insbesondere in london ansässigen
kanzlei man darauf ermahnt ihre policies
und ihrer compliance vorschriften
dahingehend überprüfen dass sie nicht
weiterhin für diese auf den
sanktionslisten stehenden unternehmen
und personen weiterhin tätig sein kann
also ist er im grunde genommen die ganz
interessante konstellation jetzt das
eigentlich ja das was für eine
selbstverständlichkeit
normalerweise ist nämlich dass leute
rechtsrat kaufen können dass rechtsrat
gegeben werden darf jetzt hier in diesem
konkreten fall nicht mehr gilt also
tatsächlich stehen dann diese
unternehmen und privatpersonen und
oligarchen ohne rechtliche beratung hier
in europa da oder ja ja das könnte man
sicherlich unter anderem kontext fassen
den wir auch immer wieder mal im podcast
benannt haben zugang zum recht access to
justice da könnte man zumindest an
diskutieren ob man diese personen oder
personengruppen rechtzeitig ausschließt
auch da habe ich mit diversen juristen
auch schon die hintergrundgesprächen
diskutiert und es ist wohl so einhellige
meinung dass man einerseits sagen kann
das jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr auf dem
kontinent schaut und damit europa ist ja
eigentlich auch für den anwalt keinen
kontrahierungszwang gibt also man muss
ja nicht mit dem mandanten
weiterhin das geschäft fortführen man
kann die anderen themen auch sagen ich
lege das mandat nieder oder wir lassen
des ruhmes ist ja auch was man viel von
vielen internationalen kanzleien hört de
facto es gibt eigentlich wenn man jetzt
nach deutschland schaut vergleichbare
nur zwei situationen und anwalt das
nicht machen kann und die treffen hier
in unserer situation mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht zu das eine ist
eine pflichtverteidigung
strafrecht da ist mir jetzt auch keinen
fall geläufig wo die sagen oder ist
schon mal irgendjemand gerade von den
sanktions bewährten personen vor allem
deutsche strafgericht und steht da auf
einmal ohne strafverteidiger dass wir
das thema und das andere
geräte also das kann eigentlich auch
dann gar nicht sein also dass die
strafverteidigung ist das absolute
minimum na also kann jemand massenmörder
sein terrorist wie auch immer eine
verteidigung kriegt er immer er wird
immer ein pflichtverteidiger für herrn
auf jeden fall und das andere wäre auch
das ist hier sehr weit hergeholt in eine
pflichtberatung nicht verteidigung
konkrete weise im bereich des
sozialrechts aber reden wir wirklich
über menschen die sich keinen anwalt
leisten können und wir wissen beide das
ist überhaupt nicht dass das trifft
nicht zu nicht diese person über die wir
gerade ein teil des problems deswegen
wird die diskussion in deutschland gar
nicht so über
strafrechtliche folgen geführt
ich bin da auch im austausch gewesen mit
der bundesrechtsanwaltskammer und habe
da mit dem vize präsidenten gesprochen
andere haupt er ist auch gleichzeitig
der der präsident der
rechtsanwaltskammer in karlsruhe und
hauk sagte dass man ganz klar davon
ausgeht dass ich deutscher anwalt eine
recht und gesetz halten es gibt so eine
ansage wie wir sie eben gerade schon
gehört haben aus dass christen gibt es
in deutschland vergleichbar nicht
meint aber auch dass anwälte schon genau
prüfen müssen wie es jetzt in den
aktuellen daten weiter geht für
russische mandanten ob die
möglicherweise hier betroffen sind von
den sanktionen denn da ist auch klar die
eu-sanktionen
stellen gewissermaßen
ein hindernis dar und können natürlich
in gewisse strafrechtliche vorwürfe
irgendwann mal münden oder und
ordnungswidrigkeiten und wenn ein
rechtsanwalt dasein anwaltliche
tätigkeit beratung verträge aufsetzen
cetera fortsetzt dann ist er
gewissermaßen gehilfe bei in der
fortführung dieser taten und könnte sich
irgendwann mal auf der strafrechtliche
neben einer beihilfe tat
strafbar gemacht haben oder könnte
ermittlungen nach sich ziehen die bank
macht in dem zusammenhang aber auch
deutlich dass das dann erst mal eine
sache der strafverfolgungsbehörden wäre
in deutschland die dann erst mal einen
anfangsverdacht nachgehen müssten dank
ihres jahres ermittlungen dann erst auch
zu einem strafprozess eben gegen den
haupttäter und danach gelagert erst
gegen den anwalt also dass wir über
mögliche berufsrechtliche konsequenzen
erst mal gar nicht reden müssten denn da
ist die bravo als berufsordnung für
anwälte an dem punkt etwas schwammig das
kann man da nicht genauer aus lesen in
dem kontext aber ganz klar ist wenn es
irgendwann mal dazu käme dass diese
unternehmen diese person einerseits
ordnungswidrigkeiten oder straftaten
begehen und anwalt beteiligt sich daran
nehmen wir weiterhin berät dann bitte
irgendwann in zukunft mit der konsequenz
rechnung müssen
herzlichen dank markus für diesen
einblick vielen dank dafür die zeit
danke dir
so nachdem wir jetzt sehr lange über die
ukraine krise den ukraine krieg
gesprochen haben kommen wir jetzt zu
einem ganz anderen thema nämlich zum
verwaltungsgericht köln und der
delikaten frage was darf eigentlich der
verfassungsschutz in bezug auf die afg
ist ja ein verfahren das für lange lange
zeit für aufregung gesorgt hat und meine
kollegin die lehne bobrowski war
verordne sie alle ihr alle kennt sie
schon sie ist ja auch gastgeberin des
faz einspruch podcast und helene wie war
es denn wie war es vor dem
verwaltungsgericht köln es war vor allem
ein langer tag es ging morgens 10 los
und nach zehn stunden verhandlung war um
acht das urteil da und ergebnis ist
tatsächlich gfd darf vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet werden sie
ist als sogenannter verdachtsfall
eingestuft das verwaltungsgericht köln
sid hinreichende anhaltspunkte dafür
dass es sich um eine extremistische
bestrebungen handelt das ist also ein
schon ein paukenschlag gewesen
nachdem ja schon der verfassungsschutz
vor einem jahr die afg als
beobachtungsobjekt einstufen sollte und
dass dann eben per eilbeschluss erstmal
untersagt wurde und jetzt quasi der
verfassungsschutz ein jahr lang warten
musste sich auch ein bisschen beschwert
hat dass er nichts tun konnte in dieser
ganzen zeit und
da lag ihr die die bundestagswahl ja da
zwischen der wollte man kein politisches
signal senden aber wie überraschend war
es denn jetzt dass man dann doch so
deutlich gesagt hat stimmt alles ihr
hättet wahrscheinlich womöglich sogar
vor einem jahr schon gedurft oder ja es
wird gegen geht darum den maßstab
tatsächlich was ist eigentlich ein
verdachtsfall da steht im gesetz
herzlich wenig da ist nämlich wirklich
nur gerede von tatsächlichen
anhaltspunkten hat der richter dann
gestern übrigens ein der das sehr sehr
gut sehr souverän gemacht hat in dieser
ja tatsächlich bei angesichts dieser
verhärteten fronten dies auf beiden
seiten dieses unfassbar umfangreichen
prozessstoff allgemein bader
in diesem gerichtssaal der jahr in der
umfunktionierten saal in den kölner
messehallen waren
130 leitzordner aufgestellt das war also
der gesamte prozess stoff also und
schafft noch umfangreiche dieses
verfahren und der richter hat es aber
tatsächlich geschafft diesen zehn
stunden da sehr konsequent und zügig die
sache zu ende zu bringen und komme ich
zu meinem punkt nämlich es ging um den
maßstab nämlich um die schreibung 8 ist
ein verdachtsfall und da hat er finde
ich sehr klassische formulierung
gefunden hat gesagt naja wenn man jetzt
mal so von der polizei recht drauf guckt
würde man sagen wenn es irgendwo nach öl
riecht darf man eine probebohrung
vornehmen um zu gucken ob es da halt
eine echte gefahr gibt und man den
eigentümer oder wen auch immer mit der
gefahr beseitigung beauftragen kann und
dieser maßstab den hat er dann endlich
angekommen und quasi gefragt wie ich es
eigentlich tritt er als die nach
extremismus also natürlich das war jetzt
ein plastisches beispiel er hat gesagt
wir brauchen eben keine gewissheit dass
die partei extrem ist es ist eben
anhaltpunkte und da hat er sich eben
insbesondere an dem ethnischen volks
verständnis der af.de ja sich darauf
gestützt wurde sagte das ist eben mit
dem grundgesetz unvereinbar
dieses diese idee schon das ist passt
deutsche gebe die in wahrheit gar keine
echten deutschen sind sondern quasi nur
auf dem papier deutsche und dass das
verfassungsgericht ja auch tatsächlich
20 17 in der npd entscheidung
klargestellt dass es so ein dass so ein
volks verständnis nicht mit dem
grundgesetz vereinbar ist und
verfassungsfeindlich insofern ist das
war sage ich mal der der kerntruppe so
und was bedeutet das jetzt konkret was
darf jetzt der verfassungsschutz alles
machen ja erstmal davon noch nichts
machen weil nämlich noch ein sogenannter
hacker beschluss als ist der vaart ist
unkompliziert der ist noch in der welt
und der muss jetzt erstmal über diese
ein verfahren das ist ein bisschen
ironie der geschichte
seit einem jahr anhängig sind also
sogenannte alpha losgesagt über die wird
jetzt noch entschieden also
diese ist noch nicht entschieden worden
und mit dem wird auch dieser hänge
beschluss aus der welt geräumt der dem
verfassungsschutz erst locker sagt
irgendetwas zu tun denn die aber aus der
welt wenn dieser hänge beschluss aus der
welt ist dann darf der verfassungsschutz
eben das ganze instrumentarium der
nachrichtendienstlichen mitteln
einsetzen natürlich im rahmen der
verhältnismäßigkeit also nicht sofort
alles vor allem ich gehe alle sondern
nur besonders wichtige person innerhalb
der afd aber eben abhören von telefonen
abfangen von e-mails v leute einstellten
und all das letzte frage noch was
bedeutet das denn eigentlich für die afg
mitglieder also konkret das wurde jetzt
ja auch viel spekuliert in den sozialen
medien konkret zum beispiel
polizeibeamte oder lehrer oder was auch
immer für eine funktion müssen die jetzt
darum fürchten dass sie ihren job
verlieren nee so einfach ist es
tatsächlich nicht also es gibt zwar im
beamtenrecht ja die vereidigung auf die
verfassung und das gebot der
verfassungstreue aber es ist ein
ständiger rechtsprechung vom
bundesverfassungsgericht und
bundesverwaltungsgericht festgestellt
dass eben die alleinige mitgliedschaft
in einer partei nicht ausreicht auch
nicht ausreicht um disziplinarverfahren
zu ergreifen aus einem lassen schon gar
nicht sondern es braucht eben
tatsächlich konkrete behandlungen die
den verdacht
anlass dafür geben dass man den eindruck
hat das ist tatsächlich überhaupt nicht
mehr tragbar aber dabei muss es sich
halt wirklich um ein dienstvergehen
handeln ja es muss tatsächlich etwas
konkretes sein dass so mit der tätigkeit
überhaupt nicht mehr vereinbar ist und
sozusagen die idee die auch das
bundesverwaltungsgericht immer einbringt
ist die beamtenschaft es gibt ja auch
dass das recht zur demonstration und
sogar sie habe man will nicht mehr
warten schafft die einfach immer nur
alles abdeckt so bis zum gewissen grad
ist auch widerspruch und und ja der
andere auffassung weiter erlaubt aber
die grenze ist halt tatsächlich da wohl
jemand sozusagen
verfassungsfeindlich dagegen arbeitet
und da können sie tina verfahren
eingeleitet werden es ist ein weites
feld aber sozusagen es ist jetzt nicht
so dass dieses urteil von gestern
bedeutet zumal sich ja um einen
verdachtsfall
ein parteiverbot hinein verdachtsfall
und da ändert sich jetzt in so ein 8 mai
nicht viel genau das sollte man dieses
spiel in der tat noch mehr sein die afg
ist eine legale partei sie ist nicht
verboten und das ist auch nicht
ansatzweise irgendwas geplant
auch deutlich gemacht es streiten eben
zwei
richtungen oder zwei strömungen
innerhalb der
seen mit den sogenannten gemäßigten sind
jetzt natürlich mit dem aussteigen
gesagt
wird naja die alleinige tatsache also
eine partei muss nicht komplett
extremistisch sein dass man sie
beobachten kann sagen das reicht noch
nicht klar ist welche richtung das
pendel ausschlägt so lange darf der
verfassungsschutz sie beobachten im
rahmen von verdachtsfall also dieses
diese idee schon es riecht nach öl wir
machen jetzt eine probebohrung wie steht
es eigentlich jetzt wirklich und diese
partei mehr schönes bild herzlichen dank
helene für diesen albers köln
und wir bleiben beim verwaltungsgericht
köln allerdings bei einer entscheidung
die schon aus der vergangenen woche
stammte denn das vg köln hat entschieden
dass google und metall so mutterkonzern
von facebook und instagram der gerade
erst eingeführten meldepflicht für
strafbare postings nach dem netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz vorerst nicht
nachkommen müssen
das war irgendwie jetzt alles so ein
bisschen absehbar und trotzdem ist es
natürlich alles wie ein unfassbar
überflüssiges verfahren also wären an
uns vielleicht noch einmal kurz zurück
es geht um eine gesetzesnovelle die im
letzten jahr in kraft getreten ist und
zwar geht es mal wieder um hass im netz
und das netzwerk durchsetzung des
gesetzes uns sehr hier auch schon in
vielerlei hinsicht immer mehr lange
jahre begleitet genommen schon die
einführung war ja extrem umstritten vor
ein paar jahren aber man muss sagen
zwischendrin hat sich das zumindest
stärker bewährt als es viele befürchtet
haben
und ist ja sogar so ein bisschen
europaweit als vorbild genommen oder
auch noch und gilt so ein bisschen als
als als vorreiter
sozusagen im kampf gegen den hass im
netz und das wurde eben im vergangenen
jahr geändert da war so ein bisschen der
hintergrund zuerst mal der mord an dem
kasseler regierungspräsidenten walter
lütke wo sich ja schon mal sehr deutlich
gezeigt hatte dass eben herabwürdigende
äußerungen im netz auch in der realität
sehr schnell zu gewalt werden können und
dann hast du letztendlich den ausschlag
gegeben habe für die änderung war das
rechtsterroristische attentat in halle
also auf diese synagoge in halle wo
stefan wey versucht hatte in der
synagoge menschen zu töten als ihm das
nicht gelang hatte ganz menschen
außerhalb erschossen und danach hat die
regierung dann neues gesetz gegen
hasskriminalität und rechtsextremismus
auf den weg gebracht und zwar eben mit
änderungen im berühmten netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz und es sollte eben
darum gehen als die sache straftaten
härter und effektiver bekämpft werden
können und die täter auch besser vor
gericht gebracht werden können denn das
problem ist natürlich auch da dass die
täter im netz häufig nicht unter ihrem
klarnamen agieren und dass die ermittler
überhaupt nicht an die daten ran sie
bräuchten um dagegen zu ermitteln und
dann gab es eben diese meldepflicht der
sozialen netzwerke gehör für das ist ne
die zentrale vorschrift der
gesetzesänderungen die natürlich auch
diesen dienste anbietern also meter wie
sie jetzt ja also facebook konnte
konzern im wesentlichen oder auch google
ja doch ganz erstaunliche pflichten
auferlegt pflichten die die gar nicht
haben wollen natürlich denn die wollen
natürlich kooperieren oder sagen dass
auch immer wieder aber sie wollen nicht
dazu verpflichtet werden die nutzer
daten herauszurücken aber genau das wäre
jetzt der fall es war auch eigentlich
schon der fall und zwar seit dem ersten
februar da ist das ganze dann irgendwie
in kraft getreten und es geht halt darum
dass die sozialen netzwerke wenn sich
nutzer beschweren also sogenannte
netz.de beschwerden über andere
äußerungen dann müssen die sozialen
netzwerke sich das anschauen und wenn
sie anhaltspunkte dafür feststellen dass
bestimmte straftatbestände verwirklicht
wurden da steht so ein katalog drin also
mord vergewaltigung androhung
volksverhetzung oder kinderpornografie
dann und sie deshalb die post entfernen
oder sogar die zugänge zu dem netzwerk
sperren das passiert ja auch häufiger
als man so denkt dann müssen die
sozialen netzwerke das ans bka melden
also nicht nur die meldung an sich die
sie dann auch noch prüfen müssen sondern
sie müssen auch eben relativ sensible
daten über die nutzerinnen und nutzer
ans bka melden und da war auch beim bka
relativ helle aufregung das bka hatte
damit gerechnet dass die so um die
250.000 meldungen im jahr kriegen und
150000 strafverfahren zentral dann
durchführen müssen und deshalb wurden
wohl auch zusätzliche 200 beamtinnen und
beamte beim bka eingestellt das ganze
soll überwacht werden also dass die
sozialen netzwerke sich an diese pflicht
auch halten vom bundesamt für justiz mit
sitz in bonn das steht in paragraph 4a
netz dg und jetzt kommt der auftritt des
verwaltungsgerichts ich will
genau also das ist hier die erste
instanz die ganze christa ist auch noch
nicht rechtskräftig und es ist nun ein
verfahren aber trotzdem ist erstmal ein
knaller wenn das jetzt auch gar nicht
überrascht denn das vg köln hat jetzt
gesagt er drei also diese meldepflicht
ist vorläufig jetzt erstmal unanwendbar
die verstößt nämlich gegen eu recht und
zwar gegen das sogenannte
herkunftslandprinzip das bedeutet dass
die rechtlichen anforderungen für
soziale netzwerke sich nicht nach
irgendwelchen recht richten sondern nach
dem recht ihre sitz staats und wir
wissen ist alle sowohl mieter als auch
google haben ihren hauptsitz nicht in
deutschland sondern in irland das war
jetzt auch keine total neue erkenntnis
sondern es wurde auch im
gesetzgebungsverfahren schon mehrfach
moniert es gab sogar eine offizielle
beschwerde der eu kommission im
notifizierungsverfahren die gesagt hat
leute das könnt ihr so nicht machen ihr
könnt die die sozialen netzwerke dann
nicht irgendwie so ins ins deutsche
recht reinhängen aber irgendwie hat
darauf keiner so richtig gehört also man
könnte davon schon ausnahmen machen aber
die hätten dann relativ hohe formale
voraussetzung hat sich keiner dran
gehalten und jetzt sagt das
verwaltungsgericht in köln so nicht
leute das verstößt eben gegen das
herkunftslandprinzip
und das ganze wird jetzt womöglich auch
überholt und zwar durch die eu ebene
denn es kann halt gut sein dass der
digital services act auf eu ebene also
das gesetz über digitale dienste noch
vor ostern dieses jahres verabschieden
würde verabschiedet wird und auch dieses
gesetz hat ja zum zielplattformen
strenger zu regulieren und gibt relativ
klar regeln und verfahren für die
löschung von inhalten zumindest vor das
ist jetzt ehrlich gesagt alles noch
relativ streitig und unklar wie sich das
eigentlich zum deutschen netz.de verhält
aber der digital services könnte das
alles überholen und komplett obsolet
machen das heißt jetzt für die nächsten
monate wird er jetzt erstmal nicht viel
passieren und die sozialen netzwerke in
deutschland haben jetzt mal zumindest
ein paar monate gewonnen in denen sie
hierzulande noch nichts prüfen und
weiterleiten müssen und dann kann es
halt sein dass schon der deutschen
services eck kommt und da muss man sagen
wenn die auf zeit gespielt haben dann
haben sie es doch relativ erfolgreich
ist erstmal hinausgezögert soweit erst
mal zum
verwaltungsgericht köln dem wir jetzt
hier schon sehr viel ihre und
aufmerksamkeit geschenkt haben
so und dann sind wir jetzt bei den
nachträgen bzw unsere hörer post ich
habe noch etwas
nachzutragen aus vergangener woche das
ist ehrlich gesagt
untergegangen in diesem ganzen trubel
und der betroffenheit im zusammenhang
mit dem
ukraine krieg da ist ja auch alles was
mit corona zu tun hat wirkt jetzt so ein
richtiger mann wünschen sich fast die
zeiten wieder zurück also wie werden sie
ja auch bald nochmal haben nächste woche
kann man schon mal ankündigen wird uns
das noch einmal beschäftigen weil es ja
auch den bald den freedom day gibt also
den berühmten zwanzigster märz und da
scheint es jetzt eine einigung zu geben
innerhalb der bundesregierung was sie
tun wollen nach dem 20 märz also welche
corona maßnahmen noch in kraft bleiben
und welche strengeren maßnahmen auch
noch in hotspots verhängt werden können
das werden wir nächste woche mal in ruhe
aufdröseln dann sieht man wahrscheinlich
klarer bisher gibt es nur erste
anzeichen vorsichtige meldungen dazu es
alles noch ein bisschen im fluss aber
wir haben noch etwas nachzutragen zum
zum ovg berlin beziehungsweise da hatten
wir schon vg wer also jetzt kam die
entscheidung vom ovg die ein bisschen
das
verwaltungsgericht berlin in ihrer
euphorie gebremst haben ja übrigens auch
gleich noch einmal ganz kurz wir haben
darüber vor zwei wochen gesprochen und
haben euch da am ende gesagt so wenn er
jetzt darauf klagen wollte dass euer
genesenen status wieder von drei monaten
auf sechs monate hoch gesetzt wird dann
müsst ihr euch jetzt alle ans
verwaltungsgericht berlin handel wenden
denn die hatten die gesamte
zuständigkeit bundesweit an sich gezogen
und da ist jetzt das ovg berlin ein
bisschen reingegrätscht wer absolut also
die haben nämlich nun klargestellt
eilanträge gegen die verkürzung des
genesenen status können nicht gegen die
bundesrepublik deutschland gerichtet
werden und damit auch nicht vor dem
verwaltungsgericht berlin lang
wir hatten ja festgestellt und stand
ehrlich gesagt die argumentation des
verwaltungsgerichts berlin da durchaus
auch ganz schlüssig die im schicht
angreifen gesagt hat das ganze die ganze
aufregung die ganze debatte um den
genesenen status und um den impfstatus
insbesondere von johnson & johnson
geimpften die basieren auf einer
bundesverordnung und die
hat nur hier ihren sitz
ihren ursprung
und deshalb sei eben auch das
verwaltungsgericht berlin als alleinige
instanz zuständig für klagen dagegen ich
fand persönlich dass ich das hat höhere
lassen ich fand das auch sehr einen sehr
pragmatischen weg um schnell
rechtsschutz zu offerieren aber das hat
das anderer ansicht das
bundesverwaltungsgericht das ovg
berlin die sich das war auch so eine
schöne
formulierung hat sich bezogen auf das
recht auf die rechtsprechung des
bundesverwaltungsgerichts der sich der
senat jetzt angeschlossen hat
so das lied von ihm hat will man ja auch
hoffen er also anders als eine
verwaltungs gericht
so und da ist eben jetzt ganz klar ein
schutz gegen die änderung einer
verordnung des bundes kann im regelfall
nicht mit einem gingen gegen die
bundesrepublik deutschland gerichteten
antrag erlangt werden das haben wir ihm
einfach mal so festgestellt auch jetzt
unabhängig von corona und daran will
sich sowohl das bundesverwaltungsgericht
als auch das ovg berlin halten so und
was bleibt jetzt all jenen die
betroffenen sind im rest der republik
die können die rechtmäßigkeit dieser
verordnungsänderung nur mittelbar und
zwar im verfahren gegen die jeweiligen
behörden also zum beispiel gegen die
gesundheitsämter prüfen ja und das
ja das wird wieder die sache
komplizierter machen
muss man also es gibt jetzt tatsächlich
auch irgendwie immer mehr rechtsprechung
dazu es gibt jetzt auch ein das erste
zweitinstanzliche urteil aus bayern die
haben auch gesagt wir halten diese
verordnung ihr wisst schon die doppelte
verweisung mit dem endergebnis das jetzt
das robert-koch-institut über den
chinesen den status entscheidet und so
weiter das halten wir alles für
verfassungswidrig geht so nicht es gibt
aber auch verwaltungsgerichte die das
halten auf jeden fall ist es so dass wir
jetzt immer noch bundesweites chaos
haben ihr könnt euch immer noch nicht
alle zentral nach berlin wenden das ist
also jetzt gekippt und im moment weiß
zumindest ich nichts darüber dass man
sich auf politischer ebene jetzt mal
darauf geeinigt hätte wie man das
eigentlich wieder aus der welt kriegt
oder wie man die kogit 19 schutzmaßnahme
ausnahmeverordnung wieder so rück ändert
dass der gesetzgeber selbst zuständig
ist und nicht die zuständigkeit einfach
weg verweist ich hoffe dass er auf
nächste und übernächste woche da haben
wir ja sitzungswoche wieder in berlin
dass der gesetzgeber kann tätig werden
wie gesagt es wird ja auch jetzt die
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
wieder vorbereitet ich nehme an im zuge
dessen wird man sich auch darum kümmern
denn die bundesregierung insbesondere
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach hat
ja schon eingesehen dass das alles
andere als glücklich war was man da
fabriziert hat ich nehme an da werden
wir uns dann nächste woche spätestens
nächste oder übernächste woche damit
beschäftigen können so und dann kommen
wir jetzt zu höherer post und zum
gerechten urteil der woche das wir
gemacht haben dass wir besprochen haben
helene und ich jetzt du vergangene woche
er leider ausgefallen bis die bp und da
haben wir ja über den umstrittenen raser
paragraf 315 des strafgesetzbuchs
gesprochen der und es hat sich jetzt
gemälde im moment bei eisenach und
anderen also der wurde ja nun vom
bundesverfassungsgericht abgesegnete und
das fangen wir schon des rechtsfriedens
wegen sehr gerecht und nun kam es wie es
kommen musste nämlich das stieß auf
geteiltes echo sag ich mal so unter
anderem bei dir die bph also bitteschön
schon uns nicht du kannst jetzt mal
loslegen naja ich bin halt eine von
denjenigen die mit einer ausgeprägten
vermutlich strafverteidigerin seele mit
diesem paragraphen schon extreme
probleme hatte und ich bleibe auch nach
der entscheidung aus karlsruhe dabei
dass ich finde dass da der der
bestimmtheit grundsatz also die die
anforderungen an eine strafrechtliche
norm die eigentlich klar machen müssen
wann mache ich mich denn eigentlich
strafbar und wann tue ich das nicht halt
jetzt quasi komplett neu definiert
worden ist also ich hab diese nur die
pressemitteilung ich habe das urteil
noch nicht gelesen aus karlsruhe aber
ich habe sie gelesen und habe mir schon
gedacht alter schwede also da ist jetzt
eigentlich überhaupt nichts mehr drin wo
man sagen könnte als potenzieller
straftäter oder potenzielle straftäter
in die am steuer eines autos sitzt weiß
ich wann ich mich da eigentlich strafbar
mache wegen eines sogenannten allein
rennens oder wann ich das nicht mehr
machen das ist überhaupt nicht mehr
gewährleistet und diese gesamte
subjektive komponente die im gesetz
steht ich muss das eigentlich machen um
quasi einen allein rennen fahren zu
wollen die ist jetzt halt völlig über
die wupper also der gesetzgeber wollte
damit eigentlich rücksichtslose allein
rennen unter strafe stellen und das
ergebnis des jetzt vom bundesgerichtshof
und auch vom bundesverfassungsgericht
abgesegnet ist ist das ist jetzt im
prinzip meines erachtens das eben auch
eine fahrt vor der polizei die mit einem
allein rennen überhaupt nichts zu tun
hat sondern die zum beispiel eine flucht
ist die kann eben als allein rennen
bestraft werden und das ist schlicht
nicht das was im gesetz steht und auch
nicht das was der gesetzgeber gewollt
haben und zwar kurz hat zu keinem
zeitpunkt also ich war schon
einigermaßen geschockt und finde das ist
eigentlich nicht mehr das was man sich
unter einer auch nur im ansatz
bestimmbaren strafnorm vorstellen kann
so mal kurz dazu manfred und je aber er
ist auch total richtig und jetzt kann
ich das flankieren durch eine sehr
kundige hörer mail wird die ich mich
wirklich ungemein gefreut hat und die
ihm auch sehr interessant ist deswegen
wollte ich sie jemand zumindest in
teilen vorlesen denn die post kam von
einem abgeordneten praktika im
strafrecht an der universität konstanz
aber noch viel wichtiger zu wissen vom
vorgelegen den richter also derjenige
der uns dieses verfahren beschert hat
und deren also derjenige richter der
gesagt hat ich halte diese vorschrift
für verfassungswidrig und deshalb lege
ich sie jetzt im
bundesverfassungsgericht vor und
zunächst ich bin nicht alles vorlesen
war es war wirklich ein sehr langer und
eine sehr ausführliche e mail wie gesagt
die ich wahnsinnig erhellen fand also
deswegen herzlichen dank dafür aber ich
bin mal kurz in in auszügen vor tragen
ist deckt sich natürlich im wesentlichen
mit dem was du auch gesagt hatte
zunächst aber das ist eins ist auch ganz
wichtig deswegen stelle ich es mal voran
zunächst legt er wert darauf dass auch
ein amtsgericht und dort auch der
strafrichter zur vorlage zum
bundesverfassungsgericht verpflichtet
ist sofern es eine vorschrift für
verfassungswidrig erachtet so und das
ist natürlich richtig und da waren wir
ein bisschen schlampig sind wird roh
hinweggegangen denn was ich eigentlich
damit verklausuliert sagen wollte meine
erfahrung nach finden amtsrichter
normalerweise nicht viel
verfassungswidrig genug sagen wir mal so
um eine vorlage zu machen so aber eher
als zuständige amtsrichter sah sich eben
zu verlagern weil er ähnlich wie du die
vorschrift auch nicht mit der verfassung
vereinbar hielt und dann geht es
natürlich direkt nach karlsruhe und auch
er ist eben sehr enttäuscht über das
wasser kam und
er hatte eben gehofft mit der richter
verlage dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht dem tatbestand
der gestalt kontur verleihen würde das
der gesetzgeberische wille sich auch in
der norm widerspiegelt und er meint dass
es eben schlicht und ergreifend nicht
der fall und ich zitiere jetzt wörtlich
aus dem brief mann hatte eine diffuse
vorstellungen vom guten und vom bösen
raser von der eiligen pizza lieferanten
und dem fast and furious charakter doch
wie diese personen identifiziert werden
sollten das sollte polizei
staatsanwaltschaft und gerichte
entscheiden doch strafrecht zu setzen
ist aufgabe der legislative nicht der
exekutive und nicht die judikative wir
sollen den in den willen des
gesetzgebers ausführen nicht gesetzgeber
sein und wir sollen vor allen dingen im
strafrecht kein neues gesetz schaffen
aber dafür müssen wir wissen was der
plan hinter dem gesetz ist zitat ende so
herrlich er war eindeutig viel schöner
ausgedrückt ich wollte man kann es doch
nicht besser sagen ich wollte schon auch
dir auch nochmal raum geben damit du sie
sehen kannst dass du auch vier
bestätigungen für deine meinung
vielleicht noch ein zitat am ende weiß
auch noch sehr schön fand das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat nun nicht
nur für den einzel raser
rechtssicherheit geschaffen sondern mit
dem seinem beschluss den gesetzgeber
dazu eingeladen
konturlose strafrecht zu schaffen also
das ist der frust eines ehemaligen
amtsrichters inzwischen ist es ja nicht
mehr mit seiner vorlage vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht ich finde das
kann man sich durchaus auch mal zu
herzen nehmen deswegen habe ich hier
auch ein bisschen ausführlicher
vorgestellt wie gesagt freut uns immer
wirklich sehr wenn wir nachrichten von
ihnen hören von euch hören und auch ja
durchaus auch kritik zu dem was wir aus
geführt haben da würde ich jetzt gleich
noch mal die e mail sagen also das ist
ein spruch podcast faz.de und insofern
auch bitte in zukunft immer gerne
rückmeldung so und jetzt sind wir aber
beim gerechten urteil dieser woche
bitteschön pia ich habe ein
wunderschönes gerechtes urteil dabei
nicht nur wie so häufig im ergebnis
sondern dieses mal auch in der
begründung finde ich zumindest und zwar
hat das bayerische oberste landesgericht
sein urteil vom 25 februar begründet
also dieses urteil ist schon in der
öffentlichkeit aber gestern wir zeichnen
auf am mittwoch kam die begründung dafür
dass das bayerische oberste den
freispruch für einen ordensbruder
bestätigt hat der einem geflüchteten
kirchenasyl gewährt hatte so dass jetzt
schon mal irgendwie ein hübsches
gerechtes urteil denn man mag natürlich
erst mal per se auf emotionaler ebene
menschen die kirchen asyl gewähren
geflüchtete sozusagen ansonsten das land
verlassen müssten also es ging hier um
einen geflüchteten der von august bis
dezember 2020 im kirchenasyl war also
der hat unterkunft und verpflegung
bekommen von diesem mönch ich hoffe
übrigens das boarden bruder irgendwie
mit noch nicht richtig übersetzt ist wir
sind auch da dankbar wenn wir irgendwie
informationen dazu kriegen sollte dem
nicht so sein und die sage flüchtete der
kam über rumänien in die eu und deshalb
hatte das bundesamt für migration und
flüchtlinge das bamf seinen asylantrag
auch nach der einreise in deutschland
abgelehnt unter verweis auf dublin 3 wir
hatten es vorhin das ist das was für die
ukrainerin und die ukraine derzeit
ausgesetzt ist es geht also darum dass
deutschland gar nicht zuständig ist für
die asyl prüfung sondern dieser mann war
eben über rumänien eingereist und
deshalb ist er auch dort als
asylsuchende registriert rumänien wäre
also zuständig für ihn
und das wusste dieser mensch auch hat
ihn aber trotzdem aufgenommen und das
dem bands mitgeteilten und das hat auch
durchaus einen handfesten zweck denn es
gibt ein ganz festgelegtes verfahren das
war mir selber auch gar nicht so klar im
sogenannten kirchenasyl das heißt wenn
jemand also ein ein kirchlicher mensch
einen flüchtlinge aufnimmt in besonderen
fällen dann muss er das den dampf
mitteilen und zwar mit dem zweck das
noch mal geprüft wird also das müssen
sich eben auch menschen kirchliche
menschen sehr gut überlegen ob sie
solche flüchte geflüchteten aufnehmen
weil sie sagen es liegt ein ganz
besonderer härtefall vor und ich möchte
dass hier noch mal geprüft wird ob
dieser mensch nicht irgendwie in
deutschland doch bleiben kann also ob
das band vor allem nicht sagen kann wir
sind aus bestimmten besonderen gründen
die ihm abweichen von der norm hier
ausnahmsweise doch mal zuständig und
dann wäre eben nicht rumänien zuständig
und er müsste nicht rück überstellt
werden so also gibt so eine richtige
vereinbarung zwischen den kirchen und
dem bundesamt für migration und
flüchtlinge für diese dublin-fälle und
wenn bis dann das band noch einmal
entscheidend sind die asylsuchende dann
quasi geduldet die behörden verzichten
also darauf ihren die die abschiebung
durchsetzen so auch in diesem fall
geschehen das bauamt hat sich das
nochmal angeschaut und hat dann im
oktober 2020 mitgeteilt kein selbst
eintritt heißt also wir gehen hier nicht
aus irgendwelchen politischen oder
humanitären gründen ausnahmsweise davon
aus dass wir doch zuständig wären und
hat dann eine kurze frist gesetzt dass
dieser mann das kirchenasyl verlassen
muss hat er nicht gemacht er ist dort
geblieben und zwar selbstverständlich
mit billigung
dieses mönch und hat dann erst nach
ablauf der überstellung frist zu
kompliziert zu tiefes asylrecht als
deutschland also wieder zuständig für
ihn war das kirchenasyl verlassen so das
passiert natürlich jetzt gar nicht so
selten aber in diesem fall hat die
staatsanwaltschaft angeklagt und hat
diesen morgens bruder angeklagt wegen
unerlaubter beihilfe zum unerlaubten
aufenthalten dass es eine strafnorm im
aufenthaltsgesetz und vor dem
amtsgericht hatte der ordensbruder sich
damit verteidigt dass er gesagt hat er
guckt sich das natürlich sehr genau an
in welchen besonderen ausnahmefällen er
geflüchteten schutz gewährt und hat eben
gesagt er weiß aus langjähriger
erfahrung im umgang mit geflüchteten
dass es da eben zu starken
traumatisierungen kommen kann gerade
auch wenn es um rückstellungen nach
rumänien geht und so weiter und er sagte
ich gucke mir das immer genau an um
irgendwie zu tun damit die leute hier
geschützt werden und wenn das bamf dann
trotzdem negativ entscheidet dann sieht
er sich aufgrund seiner christlichen
grundüberzeugung nicht dazu imstande
einem geflüchteten den schutz der
abteilung versagen und ihn zu zwingen
die abteil zu verlassen hat sich also
auf artikel 4 berufen religionsfreiheit
und gewissen spaß aber ehrlich gesagt so
ein bisschen schwierig ist weil das
schon zu sonderrechten der kirche
führten das überträgt dann quasi einem
mönch die entscheidung darüber wie
deutsche gesetze angewendet werden
sollen und in welchem fall nicht mehr
tatsächlich ist das ziemlich genau das
was das bayerische oberlandesgericht
dann auch gesagt hat er tatsächlich
recht bekommen vor dem amtsgericht das
amtsgericht hat gesagt ja der hat vor
den tatbestand erfüllt das war aber
entschuldigt aus gewissensgründen und
das ganze ist dann in revision gegangen
die staatsanwaltschaft hat also revision
eingelegt und jetzt hat das bayerische
oberste zwar diesen freispruch gehalten
für den mensch allerdings mit einer ganz
anderen begründung und zwar einer
wirklich sehr kreativen begründung und
die haben das offen gelassen ob man sich
im notfall auf dieses grundrecht aus
artikel 4 also auf die religions- und
gewissensfreiheit wirklich berufen
könnte und haben gesagt darauf kam es
gar nicht an weil der ordensbruder schon
keinen tatbestand verwirklicht hätten
das ist wirklich also eine sensationell
argumentation da lacht das das juristin
herz sozusagen das bayerische oberste
sagt bis das bank mitteilt dass es immer
noch nicht zuständig ist also während
dieser prüfungen die das bauamt sich das
dann nochmal anschaut ob sie vielleicht
doch ausnahmsweise zuständig sind gab es
ja gar keine haupt part des
asylsuchenden und damit konnte der
mensch sich ja auch nicht strafbar
machen denn der asylsuchende war ja
faktisch rechtlich geduldet und dann
geht es eben um diesen zeitraum nach
dieser negativ mitteilung also nach der
mitteilung dass bank sagt nö du musst
aber hier trotzdem im überstellt werden
nach rumänien raus mit dir aus dem
kirchenasyl und jetzt kommt das
bayerische oberste und sagt da hat gab
es auch keine strafbarkeit denn ab jetzt
lag der schwerpunkt der vorwerfbar gheit
in dem was dieser mensch getan hat nicht
mehr im tun sondern dem unterlassen was
ging nämlich darum dass er den
geflüchteten nicht aus dem kirchenasyl
quasi entfernt hat und dann prüft das
bayerische oberste ganz brav durch für
eine strafbarkeit wegen unterlassens
bräuchte man eine garantenstellung
und die lehnt das bayerische oberste
landesgericht ab und sagt es gab kein
pflichtwidriges verhalten denn dieser
mensch hat sich genau an das verfahren
gehalten dass zwischen den kirchen und
dem bund vereinbart wurde es gab keine
gewehrs übernahme weil es eben auch in
dieser vereinbarung keine pflicht gibt
die sagt dass die dass das kirchenasyl
aktiv beendet werden müsste und auch
keine bestimmte verantwortung für
irgendwelche räume oder so denn die
staatlichen behörden hätten ja nur für
diesen zeitraum auf die vollstreckung
verzichtet und dann sagen wie es gibt
hier keine beihilfe durch unterlassen
denn wir haben eben keine keine garantie
stellen also ist übrigens auch dann
tatsächlich für prüflinge jetzt sehr
interessant das ist hoch interessant
finde ich nämlich auch sie sagen sogar
noch ganz explizit ist wäre eine
beihilfe durch tun gewesen wenn der
geflüchtete von anfang an gar nicht
vorgehabt hätte das kirchenasyl zu
verlassen falls das bmz negativ
entscheidet und der mond das gewusst
hätte dafür gab es aber ebenso wenig
anhaltspunkte wie dafür dass er ihn
irgendwie aktiv zum bleibe gestärkt
hätte also wenn er ihren jetzt beraten
hätte und gesagt hätte dass beim hat
zwar gesagt du darfst hier nicht bleiben
aber bleibt trotzdem dann wäre es
natürlich eine beine nämlich aktivsten
gewesen und dann kommt aber genau das
argument dass du auch gerade gebracht
hast da sagt das bayerische oberland des
obersten landesgericht das haben wir
jetzt offen gelassen weil wir hatten ja
keine beine für durch aktives tun aber
diese möglichkeit sich dann ernsthaft
auf die religions- und gewissensfreiheit
zu berufen um aus der strafbarkeit
rauszukommen die sehen wir eigentlich
nicht finde ich nämlich auch dann sagen
die wirklich also sehr hübsche zitate
die rechtsordnung kann die geltung von
strafnormen nicht von der zustimmung
durch den einzelnen abhängig machen und
aus der gewissensfreiheit kann man nicht
das recht ableiten staatliche
entscheidungen zu korrigieren ich finde
gerade in diesen zeiten mit all diesen
corona leugnern und so weiter die die
die eigene überzeugung kann nicht zum
maßstab der gültigkeit demokratisch
legitimierte regierung oder ihrer
anwendung gemacht werden das finde ich
ehrlich eine super gute begründung denn
dass das ergebnis ist halt super richtig
und gerecht natürlich aber die
begründung trotzdem nicht zu verurteilen
ist natürlich extrem kreativ und
juristisch hoch interessant ich bin
begeistert ja ich die begeisterung
versteht ich finde es ehrlich gesagt
schon so ein bisschen ganz klein
bisschen schräg weil man muss
ehrlicherweise sagen also damit laufen
solche strafverfahren in solchen
konstellationen
grundsätzlich ins leere dann kann man
sich also die ermittlung sparende die
konstellation die situation wird immer
so sein dass man erstmal
kirchenasyl gewährt das mit der dampf ab
spricht in der zeit gibt es noch kein
straftatbestand und dann tut man halt
einfach nix danach also ich finde auch
das ist schon ein bisschen
grundsatzurteil wenn man sich jetzt
nicht vollkommen dämlich anstellt dann
ist es natürlich in der tat nicht so
dass man sich vorab schon überlegt also
keinesfalls das bauamt jetzt negativ
entscheidet dann bleibst du aber mal
trotzdem hier und so ne denn dann hätte
man ja ein aktives tun aber
wenn man sich da einigermaßen clever
aufstellt dann ist es schon relativ
grundlegendes urteil das sehe ich auch
so in sachen kirchenasyl also da hat das
bayerische oberste unter umgehung dieser
merkwürdigen artikel 4 argumentation
durch diese unterlassens konstruktion
schon im grundsatz und ja ich bin
gespannt ob wir da noch andere meinungen
hören zum thema kirchenasyl ja und zur
sinnhaftigkeit dass sie das herz rührt
kann ich auch schon verstehen ich bin da
immer so ein bisschen kritischer ich
finde das schon
natürlich schwierig wenn sich eine
institution da recht herausnimmt die
andere schlicht nicht haben auch wenn
ich natürlich auch sehr gerne dem ein
oder anderen asyl gewähren würde ohne
dass dies dürfte aber gut ich bin
gespannt das können wir mal in die hände
unserer hörerinnen und hörer legen was
ist eure meinungen genau dann sind wir
jetzt am ende unserer sendung und ich
kann vielleicht bei diesen in sieben
zusammenhang noch einmal auf unser
unsere umfrage verweisen wir würden
wahnsinnig gerne ihnen und euch ein paar
fragen stellen all diejenigen die es
noch nicht getan haben
das sind fragen zu unserem podcast das
würde uns wahnsinnig weiter bringen wenn
wir da ein bisschen mehr über ihre
hörgewohnheiten müssten auch fragen zu
unserem produkt unserem faz einspruch
produkt das ja sozusagen hier den ganzen
zugrunde liegt und das können wir
verzieren mit einem gewinnspiel dass er
sich also wer immer da mitmachen möchte
kann dies gerne tun
wer die umfrage eben gemacht hat und
jetzt gewinnen ist das gibt's ja heute
gewinnen ist eben eine reise nach berlin
zu uns gibt auch eine kleine führung
durch die redaktion und wir machen ja
live podcast am 13 06
hier in berlin in unserem atrium das
machen
ich habe genau weil du ja leider in köln
war für dich finden wir auch noch mal
andere möglich greife ich weile dann den
könig weiter dann immer so das kann
natürlich auch sondern genau also bitte
bitte mitmachen fragen beantworten
gewinnen und dann sind auch tatsächlich
alle glücklich und wir bedanken uns für
die aufmerksamkeit dieser für diese
wirklich doch recht längliche sendung
aber die zeiten sind nun mal so bleibt
uns gewogen hat eine gute woche trotz
allem ja bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]